this is jocko podcast number 293
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
hicks and gracie approached me and asked
me if i wanted to train with him
yes sir at that time i was a blue belt
in jiu-jitsu
a lean 225 pounds i worked out every day
and had been training jiu-jitsu hard for
about two years
i had competed at the blue belt level
and won many
competitions i trained daily in san
diego with dean lister a future world
champion
and with many other highly skilled
jiu-jitsu practitioners
i was focused and motivated
and determined
but none of those things mattered hixson
who was 40 pounds lighter than me made
me feel
like a child he effortlessly controlled
my movement
isolated my limbs and submitted me over
and over and over again i fought hard
applied technique after technique made
adjustments
tried to surprise him used all the
strength and trickery
and skill and effort i could muster
my resistance was futile
there was nothing i could do nothing
when he was bored with my pitiful
attempts at survival
we stopped sparring and talked for a bit
he asked me about seal training he
related to the warrior culture of my
occupation
he also gave me an assessment of my
jiu-jitsu quote
you do a good job staying calm in bad
positions
that is an important thing end quote
soon the class was over we shook hands
and i thanked hixon for his time and for
his knowledge
and over the next few days i thought
about what he had told me
you'd do a good job staying calm in bad
positions
that is an important thing
i realized that this did not only apply
to jiu jitsu
it applied to my job in the seal teams
as well
you are going to get put in bad
positions the enemy might get the upper
hand
you might be outnumbered or outgunned
panic will destroy you you have to stay
calm and that was only the beginning of
the correlation i began to see
from jiu jitsu to combat to leadership
to business
and to life itself
as i continued to learn jiu jitsu and
progress in my seal career
jiu jitsu taught me much but it was
hixson's words that initiated my journey
the principles of jiu-jitsu can be
applied to every endeavor in life
you have to stay calm when you are in
bad situations
you need to cover and conceal your
intent with other maneuvers
you need to utilize the simplest and
most efficient methods
you need to prioritize your focus of
effort
you need to train until you trust
yourself to move intuitively without
having to think
you need to move at the right time you
need to do to defend
critical areas you should not attack
your enemy's strong points
you must utilize leverage you cannot let
your emotions
drive your decisions you have to
establish a good base foundation to
build upon
you cannot be overly aggressive but you
can't just allow things to happen
when you make a move you have to believe
in what you are doing
you have to be mentally strong you have
to keep an open mind
you have to continuously learn new
techniques while always
reinforcing the fundamentals
you have to adapt your plan if
circumstances change
the list goes on and on
when i deployed to iraq as a seal combat
leader
i continuously operated with these
fundamental principles in my head
ones that i understood because of
jujitsu
i continue to utilize these principles
now in the civilian world as well
as a businessman a teacher a father and
a coach
jiu-jitsu gives me confidence but also
humility
strength but also compassion a
disciplined code
but also a free and open mind
as hixson says jiu jitsu is not just a
sport
jitsu is a philosophy and it is at the
root
of everything we do
and that right there is an excerpt from
a forward
written by me for a new book
that is called breathe a life in flow
and is written by brazilian jiu-jitsu
legend
hixson gracie and it is an honor to have
[Music]
hixon here with us tonight to share some
of his stories
his philosophies of jiu-jitsu and his
lessons learned
hixson thank you so much for joining us
it was an honor to have you here my
pleasure joko and uh
it's a great pleasure to see you guys
and uh
first of all i like to really thank you
and it's an honor for me to have you
do the introduction in the book was a
special compliment for me because you're
such a highly skilled
motivation warrior and
with all your sayings
let's kind of establish a very high high
end for my
my journey so i appreciate your support
my brother
yeah i've often talked about the fact of
what jiu-jitsu gave to me and what
jiu-jitsu gave to me was connecting all
these things i started to see jiu jitsu
everywhere and
everything became related to jiu jitsu
and
and really i i it was in i think it was
1996 or 1997
when i went up and i stayed in a
in a crappy hotel up in los angeles for
like
like 10 days or something and i went to
pico
your academy at pico every day and and
just
was absorbing i'm still sore from those
sessions but
i have good memories people at people
would ask me
what it's like what it was like to train
with you and um
i said i've told people if you've ever
like felt the pressure of a of a
high-powered hose
like a like a high-powered hose just
just water just bearing down on you
and when you move a little bit it
doesn't matter it just flows around you
that's what that's what it felt like
when you
when i was rolling with you i everything
that i tried you were already there
waiting for me
and and the pressure and the
tightness but at the same time the
fluidity it's hard to describe
yes jiu-jitsu is a very is a very
very special technique because
give you the sense of utilizing your
body
but not exactly trying to
stress yourself is up is a continuous
motions with leverage and angles and
and the ability for you to to bring
based on
weight distribution and and different
grips and maneuvers the chance for you
to flow into
uh harmonious
control because it's not about holding
and and fighting for but it's about to
understand
the motions and be ahead of the game
so when you escape from the neck you
already give me the arm and
the idea for the one who's suffering the
attack the pressure
is there's no relief until you tap but
for me it was just a continuous
understanding of what's next
and it's not in the ability to move
and to make it be there in the right
precision time so
it was a very interesting technique and
and
and give me this chance for really use
not only my techniques not only my
physicality but also
my mindset and my emotional control
and also what i believe is a very
important tools for the spiritual water
is using the spiritual energy from
forgiveness
and acceptance and not fear death
and accepting the circumstances in a way
to be
like you said comfortable in hell you
know
so as many things with jiu-jitsu favor
you
to to accept life as it is and transform
the battle in a ground and a growing
situation for your mind and your spirit
so
jiu-jitsu is a great component for
anyone
yeah i i try and explain to people
sometimes that when you do jiu-jitsu the
more jiu-jitsu you do
you get to a point where you can kind of
see the future
because you know what this other person
is going to do and when you know what
they're going to do
you can be there waiting for them
because you know what they're going to
do
and it's the same thing with anything
that you practice and you train and you
pay attention to
you can get to a point where you can
kind of predict the future
and i i think some people say
you know you you're a couple moves ahead
in jiu jitsu and the better you get the
more moves ahead you're going to be
yes similar to chess chess game you know
if you play a guy who's a champion he's
already know what you're gonna
when you move a piece he knows five or
ten movements ahead and he's all ready
to
strategize your defeat so i felt like
the same as jiu-jitsu you can anticipate
the emotions based on
on the mechanics and the and the tension
and
so you can capitalize basically always
in some kind of mistake or some kind of
lack of timing or something like that
so you wrote this book um i was lucky
enough like the
honor to be able to write the forward
but that also meant i got to read the
book early and i have a copy of it here
and uh just want to kind of jump into
some of the book and
talk about how you grew up which is i
mean
it's just an incredible your journey has
been incredible your whole family's
had such a huge impact on the world and
it's
very interesting to kind of hear what it
was like for you
and growing up inside this this such an
influential family
so let's jump into the book a little bit
um here we go by the time i was born
my father was already one of brazil's
biggest sports icons
in addition to being incredibly tough
fighter he was also a showman
of the highest order who publicly
challenged boxing icons
primo carnera joe lewis and ezra
charles although the boxers all declined
in 1932
wrestler fred herbert ebert accepted
17-year-old
challenged elio's your father ebert
outweighed
him by about 50 pounds but they fought
for an hour and 40 minutes before police
stopped the fight
two years later my dad fought 225 pound
world champion wrestler logic zebico to
a draw
when japan's greatest judoka masahiko
kimura traveled to brazil in 1951 elio
also
challenged him kimura agreed to fight my
dad
if he could first defeat yuku yukio
kato one of the black belts traveling
with him my dad's first fight with cato
was declared a jaw but elio choked him
unconscious in the rematch clearing the
way for a match with the judo champion
elio and kimura squared off in front of
000 spectators a week later
and even the president of brazil
attended the match the judoka outweighed
my dad by 80 pounds and threw him around
the ring like a ragdoll
but could not finish him at one point my
dad went unconscious
but because he didn't tap kamira thought
the choke wasn't working
and released it and alio regained
consciousness
13 minutes into the fight the judo
champion secured a bent arm lock
and again my dad refused to tap kimura
kept twisting and ripping at his
shoulder
still alio refused to tap but kimura
kept cranking
and my uncle carlos threw in the towel
my dad later said he got his samurai
spirit from
kimura and named the bent armlock the
kimura
so there's your dad how much did your
dad weigh 140 pounds 135 yeah
was a light guy and going up against
camiro who's
a beast and and by the way you can see
at least parts of this match online you
can go and google it and see this match
yes yes kimura was the champion in japan
which is very unusual for a champion in
japan to become five years
consecutive champion normally every six
months they
they trade places but kimura was
established and
a true champion in the japanese
community
and when he went to brazil
my father challenged him and then he
fought kato first
and uh in the fight with kimura
kimura put in the newspaper if he passed
three minutes
he was already winning the fight like if
ifelio survives
three minutes he wins and the fight went
to 13 minutes
so in one point the whole crowd saying
oh he's
done he's done stop the fight he's
already won
but the fight continues and my my father
bet by
gets submitted by kimura and
[Music]
and even though after that fight kimura
went to my father's house with a
translator
inviting him to teach in the imperial
school in japan
because he said the jiu jitsu he knows
japan has forgotten and i don't believe
it's like that exactly
because a big part of the brazilian
jiu-jitsu
was created by my father exactly because
my uncle carlos learned from maeda
from from condi coma and
[Music]
maeda was a champion he's been fighting
for all over and
and went to brazil to settle and he
started teaching
uncle carlos based on the friendship he
has with
my grandfather
and in that process uncle
chucalus learned a lot from from aydah
but
elio was 12 years younger than my
my uncle and was very
very young kid at this time and then
they went to rio
in 1925 cerro in rio
and my uncle carlos opened his first
school in 1925.
at this point my father was
could not do any sports he was doctor
said for him
to not do anything not playing soccer
not ride a bike not skate nothing
because
he's very skinny and he has vertical all
the time he so he's pass out any
any effort he's passing out so he had to
rest
so my uncle opened this school my
father's sitting on the corner all the
time watching my uncle teach
and for three years from 13 years old to
he was just watching amazed watching all
the details all the says all the
moves but he never practiced and one day
a student arrived at the school and my
uncle was not there yet so my father
said
mister if you want to do let's play a
little b until my brother arrive
so with that they start to practice half
hour later my uncle arrived
and the student said carlos if you don't
mind i like to keep training with the
kid because he's so
good i love to practice with him so and
that's the way
my father get into jiu-jitsu practice
but different than a normal person my
father could not do one pull-up
one pull-up or one push-up
he don't have the strength in the
muscles to do that
so he basically a choke for example
which is a
he learned as an arm movement where to
grab the collars and squeeze the guy to
choke
he could not even think about choking
somebody with the
strength on his arms so he has to bring
together and use the chest
which trans trans which transforms the
whole pressure on the choke
giving less effort muscularly and much
more efficiency technically
so that's just a very simple example of
how my dad in every movement he could do
he adapt for him weak for his own
weakness
and he's another very important element
is he was so light and so small he could
not ever
fight on top mount positions passing
guards
and and and kick axe kick kick-ass from
the top
so he was able to just stay on the
bottom regardless
and he was able to create from the guard
position
as such a new arsenal of tricks because
he has nothing to do but
guard so he developed a guard
in a very elegant style in a brazilian
style which
doesn't belong to japan at all all the
ground techniques from the bottom are
developed by
by my father which is weak enough should
not do other things
so he's improving we normally say in in
the family
elio grace is for jiu-jitsu as einstein
is to physics
he's a creator he's a genius he's
impossible to compare
and follow this this idea of of
of total connection with the techniques
and the development
the jiu-jitsu the brazilian jiu-jitsu
becomes more like
effective in the valley tudo and the
no holds bar and effectiveness overall
with ghee without gi
because gives to the weaker one elements
to
to submit the bigger one so i felt like
jiu-jitsu really becomes
a a art for a weaker one
after passed through through
brazil before cuando coma con de maida
cuomo was a very effective he has
many many victories but he was a stuck
guy he was solid
strong japanese not too tall but he was
very solid maybe 80 kilos or 85 kilos or
something so
he was dealing jiu-jitsu and his own
form of athleticism
which is different than what my dad
implies so
we are very grateful to have eddie
gracie and the family to to bring
another possibilities for our
style yeah that's um
it seems like in jiu jitsu when when you
have
jiu jitsu like that it's the situation
where like you said somebody that's
smaller and weaker
can defeat someone that's bigger and
stronger and everybody that
starts jiu jitsu for the first time when
i started jiu jitsu for the first time
you know i was like i said i was 220
pounds
my first teacher was fabio santos i
think he weighs
i don't know 150 160 pounds
he would just do whatever he wanted to
me
and he was an old man at the time he was
probably younger than i am right now but
he seemed like he was an old man i said
how's this old man with gray hair
going to do anything to me and jujitsu
allows you to do that
jiu jitsu is you know what what your dad
because he had
like you said because he was smaller
because he was weaker he had to develop
that style
and it's so effective yes
leverage replaces strength you know
techniques replaces speed so
when you have the perfect combination
you can anticipate the movement you can
use timing at your favor
and other deflections so it's a very
interesting concept of
winning without really banging heads to
head you have to make
like set him up or or fake or
set up in a way to to almost surprise
the guy with in
and defeat not exactly smash him you
know
it's too brutal sometimes it's too much
to boost fighting
you know i love to see the the
articulation of a technician
suppress the strength so for me i was
amazed about the effectiveness of
and the possibilities of jiu jitsu
i'm going to fast forward a little bit
and just so everybody knows i already
skipped a bunch of the book you know you
talk about the originations of the
family it's very interesting you know
you came from
i think you had you had a great what was
a great great great grandfather that
that was in the civil war on the
confederate side yes
the gracie family is in the warfare for
a long time
yeah you mentioned uh what was it
archibald
this guy archibald gracie and um
archer bald gracie ultra brawl iii was a
warrior at west point he
earned superintendent robert e lee's
respect after he got beaten up in a
fight on the parade grounds when gracie
was called in the lee's office he
refused to give up the name of the man
he was fighting
after his opponent turned himself in lee
did not punish either of them
when america's civil war broke out
archibald gracie iii
sided with the confederacy he started
the war as a major but after fighting
heroically in some of the conflict's
fiercest battles grace he was a
brigadier general
at the age of 29. robert e lee survived
the civil war but archer bald gracie iii
did not
yeah so that's the side that went to
america yes
i didn't know much about it until peter
which wrote the book with me
yeah he's a story historian and war
military
professor so he enlightened me with that
kind of interesting
story yeah i actually looked up on the
internet and saw a picture
of archibald gracie iii dressed up in
his confederate uniform
it's so crazy uh yeah you go into some
more of those details which you kind of
discussed
about the history of you know how it
came from japan to brazil
how your uncle got involved how your
brother got involved those details are
so rich in the book it's
so fascinating to read from a jiu jitsu
perspective but
also just from a historical perspective
in the world
i'ma fast forward a little bit to what
it was like for you
growing up you say initially we kids
went to the academy just to play tug of
war or have a game of soccer we were
introduced to jiu-jitsu slowly
nothing like what i see these days today
too many parents push their kids to
compete before they are ready
for young kids jiu jitsu should be
nothing more than a fun
form of recreation that introduces them
to the movements through games
and structured play as they get older
you can introduce more jiu jitsu but it
should be playful
if you push kids too hard too young they
will quit forever
parents should never burden their kids
with their unfulfilled
ambitions frustrations anxiety or any
other form of emotional baggage
parents support the parents support must
be cons
consistent the most important thing is
that the child gets
the experience win lose or draw
without judgment so this is something a
lot of parents need to hear this is
something i wish i would have
heard earlier i i was telling you before
we started
i definitely pushed my kids too hard
into jiu jitsu
maybe that was my unfulfilled ambitions
that i tried to
impose on my own children and
you know i i i read a book later in life
um and it it talked about how you know
you want to make things fun for your
kids and
it sounds like for you guys at the
beginning jiu jitsu was just fun
yes because you know it's a must for us
we
no matter what we're representing i mean
we are graces
we all dress geese from i mean i get my
my before my diapers so
we all become little graces and our
identity
is recognized by oh you're going to be a
champion true you're going to fight like
your dad so you you
it's a natural for you using training
inspiring
it's all fun and i never felt like it
was a serious business even competing
because my dad didn't put me pressure he
he always like
my first competition he said to me if he
asked me if i want to compete
i said yes and then he said
if you win i give you a gift if you lose
i give you two gifts
so that's kind of in in the between
lines
say my dad's not going to be upset with
me if i lose
so i didn't know what's really represent
that kind of statement but i felt like
my dad's not going to be upset so that's
a plus
and i lose that fight and i don't even
remember if i got
two gifts or not but what i felt from
that that situation is my dad was not
upset
he's okay and after that i keep continue
competing and
i i was successful in my other fighters
fights but
was a good support of my dad and no
pressure make me feel like
jiu-jitsu is something for me to
practice regardless of
somebody else's judgment you go on to
say this
you say even as a small boy i silently
observed from close proximity
fear courage aggression and cowardice
i noticed small things about people
because they provided clues about their
true nature
things as simple as the way someone
shook my hand the way people acted when
they won
and the way they acted when they lost
told me a lot
i often wondered why a guy who beat me
so mercilessly
made excuses not to train with my older
brothers
i didn't judge them i just knew that i
didn't want to be like them
there's a lot of human nature that gets
revealed on the jiu jitsu mats
oh no doubt about it man
i was young and i would start teaching
helping my brother harion to teach
private lessons i was 13 14 years old
and i was there like a dummy you know so
hicks on lay down john
mount and just to practice movements so
i was helping him
to teach and i got a little
tip after the class you know he gave me
some ice cream or some so i was there to
just watching and teaching and helping
and then i asked my dad said dad what i
should do
to be the best teacher and then he said
to me
if you want to be a good teacher you
learn a good arm lock a good escape from
the bottom
whatever and and teach your student and
you will be efficient
on do the technique but if you want to
be an excellent student
you have to see you have to try to
understand what the students needs to
learn
so it's not about what i want to teach
it's about what he needs to learn so
based on that another road was created
because i cannot just be a jiu jitsu
teacher i have to be a psychologist
and understand what i need to teach to
make
happens to make the guy seeking
happiness more efficiently
so a student who is tense and
claustrophobic i will
teach him like to be calm and relax and
do the movements almost in slow motion
for the guy who stands and try to be
tough and
aggressive and so calm down and
relax so the other guys are lazy
give up man come come come up so i i
bring the energy needs to be
naturally on him so becomes a half
psychology half jiu jitsu class
and that was a big transformation for me
because i start to understand
my service as a
something to enhance people's lives
qualities of life
you know it's not about being just a
martial arts
or or a teacher to you to fight i have
to teach you to
breed i have to teach you to strategize
i have to teach you to have emotional
control
i have to teach you to visually make
visualizations i have to teach you to
not only using the technical elements
but also the spiritual elements i have
to teach you to have hope
faith and and and things like that so
in order for you to become an expert in
jiu-jitsu
is you you basically becomes an expert
in life too because you
you know how to put yourself in
situations and be able to
to recognize the the situation and see
if you need a better calmness in your
brain
a better control in your body or if you
have to really surrender to a higher
god and and put because in one point
we cannot have be afraid of death you
know
and if you're able to understand your
mission your your
your commitment your your
honor are above that kind of that line
you become a fearless opponent because
you're not afraid to die at all how
a navy seal can go to battle not
visualizing the possibility
to die how a fireman can save a kid from
a
from a structure without the slice
chance of him to die and fall
with so once you become comfortable and
the acceptance of the
a result you're not in control you
become a much more complete
not a warrior because you just find your
mission as a priority not exactly
so in representing jiu-jitsu was a big
thing for me which
transcends my life my my
my physicality was something i put my
honor and my faith
on top of everything so i was able to
accepting challenges and be ready for
challenges which
different than a soda representing an
army which you have commands you have
uh weaponry you have
strategies you have situations which are
not exactly up to you
for me by representing my sport
i was preparing myself for no no time
limits
no rules no cups no mouthpieces
no no weight division
so how unpredictable this can be how
much
i have to be on my toes how much i have
to accept
my my final moment how much i should
have to be
calm and the day before in order to
achieve my success
so it's a lot of complex a lot of uh
aspects of my life not only the
technical not only
the spiritual not only the matter i have
to be
checking every day and being calm enough
so that's why
in my career i was putting a lot of
attention
and my breathing i put in a lot of
tension and take
bad ice baths before anyone
tell me about it so i started creating
situations which kind of put me myself
on the edge and and and being fearless
being connected with my spiritual
guidance and and accepting anything
even death if it was the case so i was
preparing myself to be a warrior but
but without the the command without the
the the force behind me was just like a
i have to create a lot of things to deal
with the pressure you know
and i felt like today i'm not a jiu
jitsu fighter anymore i have many
injuries
but i still in my mind sharp as always
using all my invisible tools in jiu
jitsu
to keep me on my best game in terms of
using
timing using visualization using
breathing using the the capacity for me
to
emotional control and and the capacity
to surrender
forgiveness and another important thing
too is
all my warfares all my situations
i don't i i don't resolve with hate
i love to fight i love to to to use yuji
so i love to represent
i love to put myself on the edge so love
was a big important part of my
my my history because i never been
ordered to do something i never been
obeying people to do something i always
a free will and i put myself in a
situation as i
i i not regret but it was tough
situations to be in
based on my own passion based on my own
love so
i being a warrior which being guided by
the heart not by the rationality
and this is kind of a little different
yeah it's it's interesting it's
different um one of the one of the
things you said and again there's so
many connections that i make with jiu
jitsu
with battle with life with
relationships with with everything and
just one little example you said
there's sometimes in jiu-jitsu you gotta
calm down you gotta remain calm you get
put in a bad spot you gotta calm you
gotta relax
you gotta not panic you gotta think your
way through it you gotta wait for your
moment
there's other times in jiu jitsu where
if you don't explode and make a move
right now it's gonna be too late
yes and you have to and it's the same
thing in
you know if you're if you're in a
business you might have a situation
where you gotta calm down you got to
make a decision you got to think through
it but there's other times where you got
to make a move right now
on the battlefield same thing sometimes
something's starting to happen
you're starting to see the enemy do
something and you need to wait
and be calm and relax and detach and not
get emotional there's other times
something happens you got to go right
now
and jujitsu you start to identify that
look there's times where you've got to
take a step back relax you've got to be
calm and there's other times where
you've got to be aggressive you've got
to make things
happen right now and those type of
lessons that
again i learned them i i learned them a
little bit
from my seal training i learned them a
little bit interacting with
my from a leadership perspective but
when i really started to see it was when
i
when i started training jiu jitsu all
the time and started recognizing oh
sometimes you got to be calm sometimes
you got to be aggressive sometimes you
got to be flexible
sometimes you got to be strong in that
position
and you got to be know when to make
these adjustments
in your life yes i feel like
with the practice of jiu-jitsu like you
said
give you more awareness of the situation
to be in
and the sense of applying
the the right the right
action for the for the situation
is is based on reflexes it's based on
practice it's based on on preparation
which sometimes that preparation
comes from understanding a strategic
understanding sometimes that preparation
coming from
a heavy training a heavy muscular and
explosive training
or sometimes the preparation coming from
a completely
emotional control i was kid about 12
13 years old practice with men's at the
academy
after the class everybody trained a
little bit together
and they all take care of me i was a kid
still and training with adults
and in one particular practice this
strong guy blue belt grabbed me gave me
a headlock
and i was caught in a headlock i was not
able to to to escape i was not able to
to be comfortable and normally we don't
tap in arm
and headlocks because you can keep and
keep breathing
but i always get panicky and tap and was
like a
disappointing for me i cried a little
bit the guy said hey kid you okay
said i'm okay thank you but i'm very so
i was pissed
and i went back home and when i arrived
i decided to lay down on the on the
floor on top of a carpet
and ask my brother holes to to i kind of
stay like straight like this
and ask my brother to roll me in the
carpet
like a like a bujito
[Laughter]
a hickson burrito yes it was like a
summer time in brazil about 110
humid you know very hot and i said just
take me
from here in 10 minutes
so first minute was struggling
claustrophobic and i started thinking
about seagulls
and breeze on the ocean and ocean breeze
and
the nice wind and i eventually passed
through the experience my brother
relieved me and then in the same year i
did three more
just to make sure i could handle that
kind of
suffocating agony and claustrophobic
feeling
so that's just to show how competitive i
was and how much on top of my problems i
was fixing my problems as i as the
problems
happened and i was just comfortable and
become you know agonizing and breathing
suffocating and then i start to become
and and find myself in peace and then i
felt
like this is not going to happen with me
anymore i'm never going to tap in
headlocks anymore because
it was just the way i felt like i was
fixing my
emotional yeah that's um
you're confronting your weaknesses is
what you're doing i remember
when i started jiu-jitsu i hated being
on the bottom
because i was bigger and if i could get
on top of someone i could smash them and
be okay
and i hated being on the bottom and for
that reason
i remember one time for it must have
been a year
every every time i rolled with anybody i
started on the bottom yes and
oftentimes with them across side or or
maybe even mount
just to get used to that and get over
the fact that i didn't like it
you have to con in jiu jitsu just like
life
you got to face your weaknesses and you
got to correct them yes definitely
now you mentioned your your brother
holes i want to give just a little bit
of background
of your family which is hard to give a
quick background of your family yeah so
many chances crazy
it's huge uh you have this section here
um uh carlos gracie this is your
uncle decided to this is he so he lost
two loves of his life he lost his
fiancee
and uh was his fiancee and his first
wife is that right yes
they both died so after they died
carlos gracie decided to father as many
children preferably boys as possible and
he encouraged my father to do the same
their goal is to create a clan of
fighters
between 1932 and 1967 carlos and elio
fathered 30 children with eight
different women
21 of them were boys when margarita
my my father's first wife the woman i
considered my mother was unable to get
pregnant my uncle came up with a plan
my father with my mother's knowledge and
consent would impregnate
our african brazilian babysitter bellina
am i saying
yes who gave birth to me
to me and my older brothers corian and
helsin
the whole thing was an elaborate ruse
margarita wore a fake belly during
belinda's pregnancies and when the time
came for her to give
give birth she went to the hospital and
came home with a baby not even her best
friends knew
when i was young i looked at myself in
the mirror and saw freckles i thought
they were from my scottish blood
little did i know i was half african
brazilian
man that's a crazy story yes man that's
part of the
the gracie fanatic idea of
growing jiu-jitsu and creating a clan
you know it was just
epic epic so
with that let me let me go a little bit
further so now you got all these brother
i'll go back to book
this is fast forward a little bit i
studied all all my brothers with great
interest when we trained because they
had different strengths and weaknesses i
want to know who was brave who was
scared
who would fight to the death who was
crazy who is indecisive
nobody impressed me more than my brother
holes a decade older than me
he was our leader and my idol because he
was an incredibly charismatic person and
a natural warrior
holes was uncle carlos's son from
claudia an 18 year old woman who worked
for my family
because my mother margarita could not
have children uncle carlos
gave holes to my dad to raise as his own
son
when he was a baby holes grew up with us
and shared a room with me for much of my
childhood
and this is what's interesting when you
talk about holes fast forward a little
bit
my brother's open mind helped him in jiu
jitsu because he was willing to look
outside of it for ideas when other
family members
were not holes trained and competed in
judo
wrestling and [ __ ] which he used to
improve
jiu-jitsu like elio he always wanted to
win by submission
and had an aggressive attacking style if
i disappointed holes
there was nothing that i was not willing
to do to redeem myself
so that's that holds
with that attitude that open mind where
he was doing [ __ ]
and wrestling i mean that's a game
changer
completely he was just such a brave
fighter on water and competitive and
with a good open mind to understand
jiu-jitsu is great but doesn't have the
the ability to to throw as a judo
doesn't have the ability to
to get some other situations like
wrestling
some maneuvers from bottom to the top
some reverses
so adding this we're not going to hurt
nobody it's just going to add for us
the capabilities of not only controlling
better from the top
throwing better from this from the
standing aspect
and also be doing what we do good
in terms of jiu-jitsu so it was just a
complete uh
improvement in our capacity to handle
the athletes all over so it was just a
great addition and for me also has
always been
the number one guy he pushed me the most
you know different than hauden which is
very technical
but harding was less competitive so and
i was very competitive so i was
seeking to to do what hollis does
you mentioned hori and here a little bit
nine years older than me my brother
horian could not have been more
different than holes alio's first son
with our birth mother
belinda horian was 10 months younger
than holes horian had an easy going
nature
and while he was never the fighter that
holes was he was a born teacher
training with horian included the theory
behind such concepts as positioning
technique leverage and base
he explained jujitsu much better than
holes who was impatient and saw things
as either black or white
he had a big influence on my teaching
style and got me to focus
as much on the person as the techniques
our father
taught us that a good teacher taught the
techniques well but that a great teacher
taught what
each individual student needed to learn
in strife
or in life horian was a great teacher
eight years older than me this another
brother helsin might have been the best
fighter in the family if he wasn't such
a wild man
helsin would show up at a tournament
having had no sleep still hung over from
a night on the town
but when he put his on his key and tied
his belt he turned into a tasmanian
devil
helsin would fight all day almost die
but win
this this is it fast forward a little
bit just a
a little glimpse into what it's like
being in the family elio encouraged
competition among us
and always wanted to see who stood where
in the gracie food chain
there were confrontations and tests my
dad would step on the canvas
tarp clap his hands and say okay whorian
holes
go and without hesitation they would
step forward and spar
holes and horian had totally different
attitudes toward life which were
reflected in their jujitsu
there was never any question that holes
was the best of our generation
now you get this sort of side of the
the martial arts family growing up
training all the time
but you're also in in real which is a
crazy place and
and the lifestyle that you had going on
there
which you which you talk about here
going to the book
rio is like new york city and bangkok
combined
it is a turbulent whatever you want
whenever you want it
mix of sex crime drugs nature
and beach culture although we lived in a
nice apartment in copacabana
rio is not like la there's not a rich
town like beverly hills and then a poor
one like compton
they are combined one minute you're in
beverly hills
and the next you turn down a side street
and you are in compton
as a kid i developed street smarts from
gang bangers to fighters to the high
society matrons
to the surfers to the most beautiful
girls in ipanema
i wanted to understand all of it i would
often ditch school and just walk around
rio i had normal rounds that i made
through the city
so you're kind of living this kind of
crazy
lifestyle yes and you're just drawn to
that
very much because you know in my house
i was the youngster and the halls horion
and helson was eight nine and ten years
older than me
so when i about 11 12 i
like to hear what they say to keep up
with you know
so for me when i go home
i was listening and learning with those
smart guys you know
and when i go to the street i don't want
to stay with the
10 11 year olds which are just thinking
about
silly things i was just walking with the
older guys talking about things i hear
my brothers talk
and the guy said hey this kid is not
he's not so he's not what he's saying so
i was trying to be very
you know compatible with the higher
level
street guys i said i see on the street
so that's kind of put me in a
in a very uh soft
place because i have to be smart i have
to be
very much solid with them
show no fear show so to be able to walk
with them to be able to get in the car
and go some
surf somewhere so i was there to just
show them i can handle you know so i was
just
give me a mission i will do you know
sometimes the guys they
they want to smoke pot for example and
nobody wants to go in the dealer's spot
because they all
want to afraid of the cops i was 12 11.
i said no i can go with my trunks i can
go up and down
hide the thing and nobody gonna see it
so i was just
being like the kid which helps the older
guys to get what they
so i was just doing things regardless
of right or wrong i just try to keep
myself in a position to be respected
from the
the boys on the hood you know and and
being like
a street guy not exactly a
a spoiled kid which forbidden to play on
the street or something so i was just
taking care of my life as a i was a girl
i was 18 19 and i was just 12. you know
and you ended up kind of running with a
gang of kids
oh yeah i mean for me it was a
demonstration of courage demonstration
of
being tough you know it was not about
doing right or wrong it's about to be
keep be able to keep with the boys and
be respected in the hood as a
as a as a guy who can not gonna flick
you know we're not gonna
so that's gonna give me a good sense of
be be part of a team which is
a tough team the guys they're all
fighters they all have kids they all
you know very very much
born to just do trouble and things
and i always start to growing up a
little bit i start to see
all those values i learn on the street
are not values i should take
in my life as a if i want to grow up and
represent what i want so
my mission my passion for the family was
take me away
from that dark side of being
just doing problems and start to become
more an athlete and becoming
completely focused on my life as a
representative of jiu-jitsu
but with a sense of base and sense of
you know
i i'm not gonna let my friends down and
i'm i'm always good
to be uh a solid you know no matter if
he's going
you know if he's a good thing if it's
the wrong thing i want to be part of
and be trusted by my friends so that's
what i accomplished
yeah it seems like you you you ventured
into that world of
sort of that gang mentality and then you
say here in the book i began to drift
away from
the gang when members started stealing
stereos and using guns
i knew they were on a path that would
take them nowhere fast and i was much
more interested in jiu jitsu
surfing and girls than a life of crime
although i was rebellious and did things
that my dad didn't agree with i never
stopped competing and never stopped
winning
in his eyes that made me special it was
about this time that i began to train
with my brother holes
up to this point alia was my teacher
whether he was surfing
training fighting riding horses hang
gliding or chasing girls
holes was constantly in motion he was
fast technical
and always pushed me to train harder and
achieve
more training with holes was essentially
fighting he reinforced what elio had
taught me
[ __ ] points [ __ ] judges win by
submission
or not at all i began to improve quickly
under holes and elio was not surprised
i wasn't stubborn and never choked under
pressure
now the expectations for me were both
from holes and my dad and they were
extremely
high how many hours a day were you
training with holes at this time
at least four hours at least two hours
in the in the morning
or or in like in the early afternoon for
classes and
and then at the training at night so i
was always
at the school you know i was never being
too much a
st a good student you know so i get any
excuse to stay away from school and
stay at the academy or at the beach but
you know it was a good training very fun
how much time would you spend
sparring how much time would you spend
drilling how much time would you spend
creating new stuff normally the class
follows up with a sequence of drilling
learning some techniques some drills and
after the freeze
for the free sparring so i follow the
protocols of the class
and i always gonna learn something
training something or grab some
improving some kind of technique and
also the practice afterwards so i just
follow the program of every class
did you find yourself in holes
especially as holes as bringing in [ __ ]
and and wrestling
would you have to break stuff down and
and kind of adapt it into jiu jitsu do
you remember doing that kind of thing
i remember hold showing the techniques
and we immediately because he also have
the eye for what's good for us or not i
was not learning from a wrestling
teacher i was teaching i was learning
from a guy who learns wrestling
but he's a jiu-jitsu teacher and tried
to favor us with
the best of it so things he may learn
and he didn't like it he'd not even show
us
he just showed the things we are related
to if the guy grabbed you here on the so
you do that so
i was just follow up his his lead on
what i should use from wrestling what i
should use from
[ __ ] what i should use from judo some
techniques in judo are suicidal
techniques
and put you after the draw you get
caught in a bad position so
you don't want to do those those
techniques so basically i was not there
to learn judo
i was actually learning efficient way to
take people down with judo
but for jitsu so was that all the
preparation the techniques are kind of
slightly different than
being just a judo practitioner yeah i
was
i was lucky uh my my son when he
wrestled
he had a wrestling coach that started
working with his wrestling team that was
a jujitsu guy too
and so he could tell him hey do this
like hey this is like a sweep hey this
is like a scissor sweep
he would be able to coach him to wrestle
using jiu jitsu
with wrestling can relate much better
yeah yeah that's nice
and uh you're surfing all the time at
this point too yes
yes you you go into some pretty good
details there about some of the um
some of the experiences you had surfing
pushing yourself a little hard sometimes
taking some risks that maybe you
shouldn't have taken in the water
yes because for me surfing was not
exactly just the practice of
the ability to go down in the wave and
carve and do this
snaps or whatever sir for me has to do
with nature with the power of the ocean
so sometimes when the waves are too big
first thing to do is get afraid because
you don't know what's going to happen if
you get pound
so dealing with this fear knowing and
strategizing the best way to go in and
out of the surf
when you get the wave the timing of the
wave so it's a lot of things which
has to keep you in control of the
situation not only the ability to surf
but to
to stay calm to to pedal in the right
direction to understand nature the wind
the
the the rip currents so it's a lot of
things to learn and to be
comfortable in sometimes in a very
uncomfortable situation so
the ocean plays a very important uh
teacher for me because you cannot fight
nature
you have to understand nature and deal
with in the best way possible
so that's surfing was a very important
for me in terms of
the reading the ocean and and stay
connected with the ocean and the more
in the in the most deepest way i could
possibly do
and surf was just a bonus
i guess it's the same thing with with
opponents right
because of opponent has some really good
move
that they're really strong at what why
what's the point in fighting that move
that they're really good at go
go at them from some different direction
of course the
the perfect strategy is work your
strengths on
his weakness so when you feel like
you're losing the the perfect aim about
where the weakness is you have to shift
not just try to force the wrong entrance
but
finding another way to to get the whole
you know
so that's the idea of jiu-jitsu is just
capitalizing on your opponent's mistakes
and be aware of
if it changes you have to flow and
change again and again so
no expectations you maybe expect a choke
but it's gonna arm luck is gonna happen
or footwork so everything can be
unpredictable if you do right
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit to
this section here by the time i was a
brown belt
my matches with my brother holes were
getting closer
i was beginning to understand the
limitations of his game
holes had an excellent neon belly move
that he used to set up arm locks
and he was lethal if he got your back
but he was also predictably
aggressive in our final 10 training
sessions not only did holes not submit
me
but i was getting reversals and our
fights were now even
one afternoon we were training together
by ourselves at my dad's ranch
the only thing i remember is engaging
with roles then going through the eye of
the hurricane with all the violence you
would expect
when the storm passed i had holes in a
choke and before i even realized what
was happening
he was tapping it was a completely
reactive fight i'm not even sure
if i was mounted around his back all i
remember is that i finished him with a
choke
nobody else saw me beat holes and when
we finished training he hugged and
kissed me on the cheek and said
you did good kid i'm proud of you
what i remember most about that fight
was the sadness i felt afterward
as though i had made a mistake by
beating him a huge
but invisible weight of responsibility
had shifted from holes shoulders
to mine in my heart i knew that i was
now a better fighter
but worse so did he it wasn't luck or a
fluke
holes just didn't just couldn't surprise
me anymore i also realized
that i would never have to beat him
again to prove it
were you bigger than him are you smaller
than him are you about the same size
i was a little bigger this time maybe
five to ten pounds
heavier he was uh
maybe 168 pounds and i'm 174.
no he was 68 kilos and i was 74 kilos
okay
yes
you get your black belt um and that's
you know this is always an interesting
thing when you when when someone
you know you get that edge on someone
that's been beating you for
your whole life yes it was a very
special
feeling because i have him as my idol
as my coach as my my training partner
and but at the same time my goal was
beating him because no other way
i have to to change this pattern i have
to
to be the best one so my goal as a
student is to be better than my teacher
and when i achieved that i felt like
somehow
was was not exactly posit only positive
the way i felt because i put him in a
bad side in a bad
mood or feeling he was not exactly
the best anymore he's number two so it
was a sad thing for me
and was a happy thing for me but
my my demonstration of love and respect
was
after that even though we going in every
tournament and i go and hit
i go in my weight division he go in his
way division
and we go both for open and
before that we close the bracket because
we could not fight before
the finals because we're representing
the same brand
so in the finals i always gave it to him
the victory rega
not fighting him and even after i could
be able to beat him
i still doing this for life you know
until he pass out
i pass away because you know i felt like
he was my i honor his
representativity on me and so he was
going to be number one and i'm number
two
for the world i can be throw the light
through the alliance
before him but in the official
tournaments where he goes
with me i never gonna be
capable in my honor and my integrity to
to take his medal you know or to fight
him or to tell him
i'm better than him so he was the
champion of the family until he passed
away and after he passed
i take i take the the responsibility for
myself
it's uh when when i train with people
and i'll be training with them for a
long time and
you know sometimes they'll say one day
i'm gonna get you you know they have
that goal
one day i'm gonna get you and i always
say yeah
of course and i and i say listen jiu
jitsu works
and if you put a jiu jitsu move on me
that i didn't expect or i didn't see
coming
will happen what's going to happen i'm
going to tap that's the way it works jiu
jitsu works
it's a beautiful thing yeah that's what
we trained for
um
you have a situation here where you had
a little lesson learned
you said i was growing so dominant in
jiu jitsu competition that when i
stepped on the mat
and the referee said go the crowd would
begin to ch
chant 10 9 8
7 6. if i didn't submit my opponent in
10 seconds they would start counting
again
even as a black belt my only jiu jitsu
fight that went more than five minutes
came after the judges robbed my brother
hoiler
of a win against one of my cousin
carlson students
my final match was in the open class was
against carlson's 240 pound heavyweight
i was so upset that i decided that i
wanted to make him suffer
after i got him down i mounted and just
put unbearable pressure on him
i was not fighting my actual opponent
instead i was trying to punish carlson
for robbing euler
i'm glad i wasn't that guy everything i
was doing was fueled by
ego and anger and i was working against
myself because my emotions were
negating all my precision and martial
artistry
i was spinning my wheels as if i were on
ice going nowhere i was just blindly
punishing him
until until holes yelled eight minutes
are up i was shocked to see
i was shocked because that was too long
i snapped to my senses got mad at myself
and easily submitted him afterward i
realized that i never
wanted to fight like this again because
i was putting emotion
before reason although nobody else
realized it at the time i learned an
important lesson that day
that it was a mistake to fight
emotionally because emotions
blinded me yes
i think the the biggest experience i
have in that matter
was on my first fight with zulu which i
was 19
he was 30 something years old he had 120
fights
and only four draws and 120 victories
so he was a professional valitudo guy no
holds bar fighter
and i was just you know watching my my
dad talking in the phone with
his manager trying to set up somebody to
fight him
and my dad said no man i'm sorry about
them i don't have nobody to fight this
guy
because you know we are and then i i
catch the conversation dad please pull
me and pull me and pull me and
and he looked at me and said yes
voldemort i have here my son with 19
years old he may want to try
and valdemar said no master no no he's
not it's not something to try out for a
kid the guy is tough he's
mean and as my as the guy
tried to talk my dad out of the deal my
dad got
information yeah but i think i'm going
to put him because i like to try the kid
see how it goes
so and then set up a fight for me with
this zulu guy
and i went to to the his state the
the capital and in the day of the
fight uh
we engage he has this kind of typical
move he does which goes and put one hand
between your legs
and and connect you and then lift
everything and throw you back on the
floor
some kind of catagorum in his style how
much how much zulu weigh
about 230 and he's just a beast
of a human you said he had a hundred and
something fights yes he was just
unorthodox he has no
sharp techniques but he was just a very
intuitive animal very flexible very
strong very mean you know
a very complete fighter for the time
and i was start to dealing with him and
as you go for his straight move and this
is what sorry for interrupting you but
this is your first
actual fight that you're ever going to
fight my first
valitudo mat yes officially on the ring
and and
how many people are at this fight about
ten thousand five to ten thousand people
and you have the gracie name yes at
stake
yes you're 19 years old yes how much do
you weigh
about once i mean 74 kilos
so about one 170 something seven
yeah 75 yeah okay so
he coming he coming for the trade move i
kind of
understood what he called me i hold his
his shoulders
and his head was down so i hit him with
my knee
the strongest heat the solid heat i
could imagine possibly give to somebody
and after the heat boom he just lifted
his he lift his hand
head shook his face like speed a tooth
and come like nothing happened and i get
scared you know i get
wow man i thought i'm going to kill the
guy and he just shook his hand
his head so we start to back to the
the the the engagement and he throw me
off the ring
i went up back again and get him in the
back
many times hit him with the elbow he
throw himself out of the ring and we
start again
and again after the first round 10
minutes
we stopped and i was dead tired
so i was crawling to my corner and when
i get the corner
said dad i quit i cannot go anymore i'm
exhausted
did not even hear me he said oh he's
worse than you you're gonna now you're
gonna kick his ass you're gonna do as a
dad i'm serious i start to argue with my
dad
trying to plead my case you know i said
hey man i'm exhausted to
cut the and he did not even listen to me
statue okay then my brother hulk throw
me a bucket with
water and ice and my head
and then the the bell rings and i back
to the action
and like my dad said three minutes after
he was sleeping i
could get his back he was tired i'd
choke him out
and then i realized my worst enemy was
my mind
was the worst enemy i could ever have is
somebody inside
your brain telling you it's time to quit
you're not going to handle the guy is
strong
so i realized if i was trusting myself i
was done
so i could not have this enemy this
powerful enemy hanging on my head
all the time so i decide now
i will fight to die but i'm not gonna
quit anymore quitting is not my word
anymore
either i'm gonna die or i'm gonna win
but no quitting so what's maybe the
biggest lesson in action i have
ever to have because i understand how
your
apart mindset can can really kill you
from within and i understood that
and from that on i was just
putting all my mental spiritual
physical in one direction and the other
direction is only death
no quitting no i think i'm done
nothing like this so my brothers has the
the idea of if something happened throw
the towel because i'm not going to quit
so and that's kind of make me happy
because i become a water in a good
direction
and thanks my dad for don't let me quit
sometimes a bad show can kill you a bad
coach can kill you if
he accept your your moments you know so
you have to transcend that kind of
panicking and and just back to normal
and
regain confidence and
after i learned that i was completely
different guy a much more
superior entity in terms of
putting everything together all my
package was together always and i felt
like
was a blessed by that
now i was going to ask you how you
changed or what did you learn from that
fight
from a training perspective what did you
do different but i know that
this is around this time at this one you
got way into uh
into doing yoga with uh orlando connie
yes i was a little before that okay
because uh since
my 12 year old where i roll myself on
the carpet
feeling the the the panicking the
claustrophobic feeling was always
close to me a little bit i always been
an athlete i always run forever
training forever and young guy was
always being natural for me
being and and fight and do whatever
but in one point if you don't have if
you don't master breathing
when you get too tired you get confused
you get your mind fading away
it's not ex enough oxygen in your brain
and your muscles for you to feel
clear mind and still getting tired and
still sharp
so i felt like was always a lack of this
you know
this profound understanding
and one day because my mother he pulled
me to do yoga in one point and i did and
i stopped because i didn't like it
transcendental meditation which make you
see it and
repeat a mantra for a while and start to
open your mind
i also end up by sleeping almost all the
time and not
didn't adapt much about it by that so it
was not for me
and then a friend recommended me to go
to orlando county which was
an army pentaton champion
he was also a yoga teacher and it was
start to develop some kind of exercising
with movement and breathing which
can be very helpful so i went there to
the sky
and he knows my dad he's very friendly
guy he said okay so goes to the class
and practice with us so i started to go
into his class with other people
and statue practice and right on the
second
time he said hickson you're very
flexible you're very strong you're in
the top high athlete
i like to teach you personally because i
can improve your speed i can improve you
personally more than the class said
great
so i started doing with him a couple of
times a week
only privately with him and his place
which is
mirrors and one side has the
the wall and has the wood attached on
the wall for you to hang
so from here to the roof all these woods
kind of
so you play different games and you
sometimes you
imitate a monkey sometimes you imitate a
eo
uh crocodile or whatever so you play
animals and moves and breeds
and he starts to teach me to work the
diaphragmatic breathing
and that's going for a month for two
months almost three months on that
one day we're about to initiate the
practice he said hixon
i mean the phone the bell rings the
phone rings
and he said you keep doing because i'm
gonna take the phone and come back
so for the first time i was doing the
exercising
without a leader i mean i was following
i was improvising myself to doing my
things and breathing
and doing my things and breathing
breathing
and things going and then eventually
i opened my eyes like wake up and i was
hanging on the top
on the top wall on the top wood in the
wall side
hanging like a monkey dripping sweat
and i opened my eyes and i kind of
started to understand where i was i
kind of wake up and i saw hold on the
city i mean standing up on the corner
and uh and he said to me
kind of crying a little bit said hickson
i don't think you need me anymore
because you achieved the highest level i
said why you say that master why you say
that
so because you're here for an hour and
15 minutes
and i call you a few times i try to get
your attention and you kind of
you cannot even hear me you completely
in a
meditative state of mind empty mind
doing your things breathing moving
and now you just wake up now you just
put yourself conscious again before was
just reflexes and subconscious mind
and i realized i could achieve
meditative state of mind empty
mind through that practice so through
that practice which i started doing in
my academy on the beach
i start to understand breathing in a
much more profound way not only to help
me
mechanically not only to help me to
to uh
charge myself and and and rebuild my
energy
from the oxygen standard point but also
to give me
some kind of meditative state of mind
empty mind
be tranquil be able to control my
emotions so this practice become
a central part of my life because
by breathing i could be able to not only
have a better
functional strength and an ability to
recover faster
from tiredness but also
what is very interesting is the lungs
because the heart
and the brain are the only organs
who are able to give and receive
information
so sometimes you can get affected by
reading a bad email you can get a stress
immediately you get affected
sometimes you see something which is
relevant somebody you love or somebody
touch you you feel immediately
emotionally by the heart it's not
they can get information and they can
send information for you and say i'm not
happy
some take care of me i'm not happy take
care of me i'm very exhausted
so you're tired your heart can tell you
or your brain oh i'm confused i'm
stressed i'm afraid i'm
out of my game so the brain and the
heart
are there to be controlled by the lungs
the lungs are the most fast
the most effective way for you to deal
directly with your brain
and with your heart
for example if you hear you just read a
bad email and you stress
so
if i keep that routine for three minutes
no stress can keep on because i have to
control
i have to integrate motion and feed
in in movement breathing and movement
together
and as i start to play on this
nothing can be like i cannot thinking
about oh the time to travel i have to go
to
san diego tomorrow i have to give my
daughter whatever it is
you have to refresh it because the way
you breathe you can really clean your
mind
the way you breed you can lower your
heart rates
for fighting for example i was doing
like i get an event
three hours before the event my fight
so i go to the locker room sleep for
hour and a half
hour 40 minutes by weew i just breathing
my relaxed breathing i can sleep deeply
wake up one hour before the fight mourn
myself up for 45 minutes
putting my heart beat my heart rates to
160 140
to really break the sweat and make sure
i'm cool
and then sit for five minutes and bring
my heart rate to 6 500
heart beats a minute so i was deeply raw
hot
ready to go with my heartbeat
so i see my other opponent in the other
side of the ring jumping around he's
already 85
90. so when i engage i engage not to
to to make some kind of nice
uh rhythm i try to to improve
press the gas and let's go for power
so we do everything we can do so if i'm
struggle you cannot rest
you have to keep up with me so when i'm
you 110 when i'm 110 150
when we're 100 when i'm 150 you're
already trying to
i had a heart attack yeah so you start
to regroup and start
seeking for air and that's time normally
where mistakes happen and i
really make the close the deal
so breathing become my best friend not
only to control my emotions
to keep my my my heart rate
and the best performance to recoup so to
be
controlling panic controlling emotions
become calm to strategize everything
coming from this capacity
within to control yourself by breathing
so
i felt like was a great addition to my
my practice and makes a huge change in
my life
this is something that i i connected the
dots on a few years ago
because people would ask me i would say
listen when things are going bad you
have to stay calm you have to
you have to learn how to you know
control your emotions and and don't get
all
excited about something when things are
going wrong
and people would say well you know how
do you do it and one of the things that
i realized that i would do
is so in the military you know you have
a radio with you
and when you when you talk on the radio
everybody can hear you
and in the military it's very frowned
upon
if you get on the radio and you are
emotional if you scream
help over here if you panic like this
so every time i ever talked on the radio
my goal was to never sound panicked
never sound emotional no matter what was
going on
sound very calm and cool so that means
whenever things were going crazy
and i was about to have to get on the
radio what would i have to do
i had to breathe i had to take a breath
and so it's the same thing it's just
that something that i was doing so that
i could
you know i'd be oh there's got stuff
going on okay i'm about talking radio
hey this is jocko we need about 10 more
guys down at this building right now
and that me taking control of my
of my breath also would help me
get into a controlled emotional state
where i'm not losing my mind
yes that's very powerful
from jiu jitsu yes because you know the
the the breathing system or because you
stay
seven days without food you stay three
days without water five minutes without
oxygen
is already dead yes so the efficiency of
the breeding system
is very needed and people take this for
granted they don't
oh i i i born i get slapped on the butt
and you are alive and well and you can
live like if you don't train in
breathing
it's like your biceps it's like your
your strategies your techniques your
if you don't train in the breathing
system you're going to work with
40 percent less the capacity
capabilities to really
refresh yourself hyperventilate
bringing yourself to a next level of
understanding because
if you get tired and you don't know how
to hyperventilate you get tired
and your mind starts to face to fade a
little bit you start to making poor
decisions you start to get
completely off your game because there's
no oxygen
enough for the brain and the in the body
but if you know how to hyperventilate
you can have cramps that's the lattice
all over you cannot even
move well very tired but your brain is
too sharp you can see details you can
see
the girls smile at you you can see the
super bowl you can see everything you
want to see
and talk because your brain is still
fresh
and that's the capacity you have to
learning how to hyperventilate and use
the diaphragmatic breathing
which improv improves your life like a
dawn
oh that's awesome stuff uh going through
the book i mean at this time
you also uh you had met your you had met
kim
yes you she got pregnant with your first
son
yes at this time um
and she was what some kind of a model
some kind of a surfer girl
she was the first sponsor surfer girl
in brazil she was doing hang gliding
she was a top model for for fashion she
do some
some uh modeling for for
soap operas and stuff so she was pretty
pretty hot girl at the time
um i'm gonna fast forward a little bit
here so you you have your first son
it says the year 1982 was a bittersweet
one
i was now the father of the son i'd
always dreamed of but i also suffered a
devastating loss
in june holes and his family went for a
family weekend in the mountains
holes noticed his old hang glider was
strapped to the roof of a car in front
of his hotel
it turned out that the owner was a
friend of a friend
even though my brother had promised his
wife angela
that he would quit hang gliding after
he'd had several close calls and friends
had died in accidents
he made arrangements to go the next day
the following day the conditions were
very bad because there was no wind
if holes got his mind set on something
however there was no
saying no to him although the owner of
his old hang glider did not want to go
because he thought it was too dangerous
holes talked him into letting him use it
for just one flight
my brother ran down the ramp launched
initially got some lift
but then began to spiral and he hit the
ground 90 yards from the ramp
his friend ran over ran into the
overgrown forest and found my brother
hanging upside down with his eyes wide
open
although he looked perfectly fine his
neck was broken
and holes was dead i received the news
over the phone
and it took only seconds to know that my
life would never be the same
not only had i lost an idol a teacher
and my favorite brother
but i was now officially the family
champion
now i would have to answer all the
challenges and lead the next generation
of gracie fighters
i was now my family's last line of
defense
his death affected our family dynamics
dramatically holes had brought
the two sides together because he was
carlos's son
but raised by elio he acted as a bridge
between the two sides of the family but
now that bridge
was gone forever
tragic yes i know uh
my my my original teacher fabio santos
yeah he he was originally uh as well
yes he was and and uh i always he
the way he talked about holes was always
uh just elevated beyond belief
yes fabio has a passion for halls not
only
for the teachings and being jiu-jitsu
guy and inspire him to
to do the best but they also have a lot
in common you know they
they go out together they so they're
good friends so
it was devastating for fabio
[Music]
at this time on top of all this you
start to have this uh
this kind of famous or infamous rivalry
with uh luta libre fighters
yes and had some um
had some uh interesting interesting
things going on there and again this
this book is so filled with so many of
these details that people will be
interested in
meanwhile you you you have a uh daughter
right yes your first daughter
and then a second daughter yeah so now
you're now you're up to three kids and
again these are all things that are
detailed in the book and
all kinds of interesting stories around
that you also say the gracie clan
continued to to divide along bloodlines
while horian was trying to establish our
martial arts in the united states
carlos gracie jr was going in a
different direction in brazil and
primarily focusing on a competitive form
of jiu jitsu
that would become known as sport jiu
jitsu
and this is what a thing i appreciated
you said i had little interest
in the politics of jiu jitsu i had three
children to support
i wanted to fight vale tudo
professionally and the only place to do
that outside of brazil
was in japan so at this point horian had
moved to america
yes and and you're looking at um
possibly fighting in japan yes going
with my friend to japan
to see if i can find some
i was having a letter of introduction to
antonio noki which was ambassador in
japan very famous wrestler
and i tried to find a pick a fight
through him
in japan so i was there but i was
you know wasn't i could not achieve my
goal
and back to brazil and and then you have
crohn is born yes and now things are
really
seem to be heating up with the lute
libre academy
and there's uh at one point
um you guys drove over to the luta libre
academy academy yes
you say here we walked in and 20 or 30
fighters stopped training and stared at
us marco who else rock
walked over and greeted us everyone was
very respectful at first
i told huas that i heard he wanted to
fight me and i was there to fight him
he said that he wanted to fight but that
would that he would need
four months to prepare this made me feel
that he was more interested in
capitalizing on the fight than
proving himself which pissed me off i
was the one who walked into that lion's
den ready and willing to fight for
nothing but honor
it started to get heated and my dad
stepped between us to calm things down
and then you have hugo duarte it's kind
of stepped in
and and you know saying hey i'll fight
you too
and then you said i had a friend tell
hugo to meet me
at pepe beach on saturday i got sick the
week of the fight and was thinking about
postponing it
until my messenger called and said it's
all set hugo will be there on saturday
now i knew there was no backing out so i
started to eat well and get ready get to
the beach
you get to the beach i walk up to hugo
and slap him in the face
yeah he took off his shirt and sandals
and we began to wrestle on our feet
until i was able to drag him to the
ground
hugo used my ponytail to control my head
and stood back up
he fell on top of me then i swept him
but my knee got buried in the sand and
hugo escaped
we stood back up and smashed into a
vendor stand that we went down on the
ground again with the crowd surging all
around us i mounted
again gift wrapped them and began to
punch him in the face at will
there was nothing he could do to stop
the punches when i asked hugo if he
wanted to give up he said
you'll have to kill me so i kept
blasting him
with punches and elbows after a few more
blows to the face
he changed his mind and said okay stop i
let him go
that that's another one you can find on
youtube that whole fight
probably has a billion views
uh um
fast forward a little bit a week later i
was sleeping when my friend pulled up in
front of the apartment on his motorcycle
and screamed hixon those [ __ ]
invaded your dad's academy
boy that seems like a bad move it seems
like a real bad move yes but
it was crazy they kind of
because they they coming for a revenge
google was prepared for
for next fight he was not happy with
what happened on the beach
so as they walking maybe about
three or four miles walk from from a
different area of the city
and and some of the guys who are with
him are coming from the ghettos you know
like gang banger so they come in with
like
the face masks on the face guns
knives bottles i mean all crazy
type of not only fighters but also gang
bangers
so when i get into the school
when i bought i was getting in my
friend's motorcycle on the
he coming to us so i was going back to
the school
on his motorcycle and i saw about 200
people in front of the school like
half of the street already with full of
guys so the traffic was jammed
so i get into with my bike with my
friend's bike ins
inside the crowd and immediately go up
to the
stairs on the to go into the school and
i meet google coming down with my father
and other guys like about 20 luta livery
guys
the students so we all meet in the
middle of the the
stairs so i said uh let's go down and
talk and fight
so we went down to the parking lot
and i and i call him with his coach
and another guy who fought higher
afterwards eugenio tadeo
they went to a corner and my father and
we
talked and i said to say hey man i
respect you
i see you come here for a revenge and i
accept that
but you brought a lot of bad guys a lot
of guys who has no
integrity no no fighters if somebody
touched the fight before is over
you're going to end up on the ditch
sometime i promise you you're going to
be on the ditch very soon
no no it's fight for men men too man me
and you nobody's going to touch the
fight it's just me
okay so let's go back to the crowd and
let's fight
so and then we kind of create a a circle
on the concrete and crowds around
me and him and i felt like from the
first
from the previous fight he felt like he
was missing the stand-up game
he was missing punch me in the face
somebody told him maybe
oh you should start fighting him
punching don't grapple him just
so i felt in his stand he was looking
for to
hit me hard you know and i play dummy i
play a kind of little unaware
and expect his attack when he come in
with a direct i deflected
grab his body lift throw him on the
ground and bang him on the concrete
mount
and start to punch him on the head he
protect his face
i put my hands on the on top of his head
and
push his head against the the floor a
couple of times
and he soft up a little bit and uh
and then he said quit stop stop stop
stop so i stop it
stand up he stood up and said okay man i
respect you
it's all cool for us now we said okay
man i respect you true you have a
potential you know you can become a
great fighter
so we shook hands and as we start to
to to finish that to terminate our
problem while we start to fight the the
eugenia tadeo right there you know
and the confusion steals and then the
police coming and one guy
a police guy very short guy with a
cigarette and moustache i cannot forget
this guy
he got a gun machine and shoot on the
roof
so the bullets touch the roof and coming
down hit somebody on the leg and stuff
and i now i want to see who want to
fight and the guy was very funny
so and then hoyler's fight was postponed
for next week
they fought again with the same guy but
my
deal with hugo as resolve how'd the
fight with hoiler go
was a draw because we put
10 guys from lu talibri 10 guys from jiu
jitsu and
an auditorium closed doors
and hoyler will fight the guy to the end
right
so and then they start to fight hoiler
get punched in the face and lost the
tooth
and then the fight continues while i
control the guy
he put the guy in a bad position but not
submitting
and the guy said okay i want to quit
if i was no better if i was smarter i
said okay stop while her win
but i was pissed and was want to see
highly revenge the punch
said okay hilar you just stop the fight
if you want if you if you don't want it
you keep fighting
keep beating this guy and the guy that
formulated stood up and said
but that's not i push him on i push him
down like
sit down here and shut up the guy was
acquitted you know he was not a tough
brave guy so he don't want to fight said
poor hicks and why you did that
no they gonna fight until the end so
they keep fighting
and eventually hoyler get tired and both
get tired so they agreed to stop we want
to stop okay stop so they stop
and it was a draw was
i should stop the fight sooner and make
her victory but it was not
exactly for me it was not the politics
or the was just you know the guy just
reserved some punches in the face and
highlighted
missed to get it so for me was a missing
point what i want to see happen and
didn't happen
man hoiler is uh he's he's i train with
hoyler and
and he helped us out at our academy here
a lot man what a great
freaking jiu jitsu player he is he's a
water
for sure 100
it's kind of uh kind of cool you know
you talked a little bit about
forgiveness already today but you you
say this in the book looking back
today on the fights between jujitsu and
luta libre i see them very differently
at the time we were all young men full
of aggression and testosterone the
rivalry between our two martial arts
made all of us better fighters steel
sharp and steel
we should all be grateful for the fact
that we always had the ability to fight
one another respectfully
although there were black eyes bloody
noses and broken teeth
our fights were always one-on-one and
were governed by honor and mutual
respect it was part of the natural
competitive process
it was no accident that marco huas hugo
duarte
denis and majia eugenie to do
my brothers and some of my cousins and i
would all go on to fight mixed martial
arts professionally in america and japan
definitely um a good attitude to have
yes
competitive but respectful against these
other guys
yes it's an honor between fighters you
know it's not about it's not something
we've
had to have integrity have to have
respect that's part of the code
you know this is something i i highly
appreciate it
the next chapter in this book is coming
to america
you say there's a little left for me to
prove in brazil at that point america
was a bigger stage and more opportunity
and i thought my kids would have a
brighter future there when i decided to
move to the u.s
kim and i had been separated for over a
year and a half
i went to see her and told her i would
like her to come with me and the kids
and give our relationship another chance
she agreed to my offer
i wanted to make a fresh start
while i might have been the best fighter
in the gracie family horian was by far
the best promoter of gracie jiu jitsu
he was a born salesman with a great
product to sell and nothing helped
spread jiu jitsu more than the portable
video camera
after horion and horian came to america
he began
challenging fighters from other styles
and videotaping the bouts
footage from these and other fights
transformed what would have been urban
myths into documented truth
in 1988 horion put together a video
called
gracie in action which he advertised in
the back of martial arts magazines and
sold
by mail order there you go that's
yeah that's that's the beginning yes
that's the beginning right there
that's when the word started to get out
yes because you
hear it but to see it is something
totally different yes i mean that's a
brilliant marketing move
hey come and fight anybody wants to come
and fight come and fight
we're going to video it and then we're
going to show it to the world yes
that's a brilliant move i think so true
he was a genius on that
i know uh we fabio when i trained at
fabios
he had uh he had some of those videos
that weren't even in the videos
and he would show them to us like on a
special friday night we'd get to watch
some
some real gracie in action videos
people's arms getting broken
because they didn't want to tap exactly
uh you go on here our students regularly
fought and won challenge matches against
other fighters and then converted them
into students
chuck norris for one the actor in
american martial arts icon was not only
a great supporter but
was also a dedicated student who
eventually earned his black belt
in the 1980s norris took a vacation in
rio everywhere he went heard about
gracie jiu jitsu
and the exploits of my family norris
contacted my dad and arranged to have a
private lesson
after i grappled with him my dad told
norris to mount him
and when he he did said okay chuck punch
me
the american hesitated but my dad was
was in his 70s
by then but elio kept insisting finally
norris drew back his arm to punch but
before he could throw one
the old man had choked him out chuck
left brazil impressed by the gracie
family and invited us to come to america
and hold a seminar for his students
fast forward a little bit horion and the
actor had a disagreement over money this
is after one of those seminars chuck
norris hired our cousins the machado
brothers
carlos higgins hodger jean-jacques and
john to teach him the machados came
from a more stable upper middle class
background than we did
their father was a judge and they did
not grow up in rio not only were they
much more reasonable than horion
they were great jiu jitsu fighters and
teachers in their own right my cousin
jean-jacques machado
is an inspiring person who went on to
become one of the greatest jiu-jitsu
teachers in america
born with only a thumb and part of a
pinky on one of his hands
jean-jacques learned how to adapt and
improvise
better than anyone i had ever seen his
jiu-jitsu is both intensely personal
and creative
so he had the machado brothers now
teaching chuck norris
yes but you did there's a there isn't
there there's a video of you going
against chuck norris isn't there
is a little mistake on that video that
video in the seminar
is a very strong talk blonde guy who was
a
struck notice good student tough tough
fighter it was not chuck
at that time got it i sparred with chuck
i teach him a few times and i sparred
with him a few times so
he knows our power but the training was
not with him at the time
um you when you showed up in
in america you didn't even speak you
didn't speak any english did you know
where'd hori and learn to speak english
he come
prior that he coming few times to
america in the 70s and
stuff so he he loved here the culture
and his statue learning and
working different jobs and tried to make
hollywood
work as an actor as a stent man so he
was
and he likes to speak the language so he
he learned very
quickly and very effectively
fast forward a little bit even though
alia wanted horion
to lead the gracies in america it was
easier said than done there were just
too many of us moving in different
directions and horion's efforts to
control the clan backfired
after he threatened to sue members of
the gracie family
whom he had grown up with on the mats
for using their own gracie last name
many family members surrendered gracie
jiu jitsu got renamed
brazilian jiu jitsu i believe that if my
brother had allowed everyone to use our
family name
our martial art would still be called
gracie jiu jitsu today and perhaps
it'd be even bigger than it is so i
wanted to mention that part in the book
because
i think echo charles and i get asked at
least 10 times a week
you know should i train gracie jiu jitsu
or brazilian jiu jitsu what's the
difference between the two
is there a difference between the two
and i think you summed it up right there
pretty well
i think we start doing
jiu jitsu in the protocol where you have
to learn self defense
you don't have you're not required to
use collar belts no collar belts at that
time
so a student can be 10 years a student
in a steel white belt
and the structure will be forever a dark
blue belt
so that's what's the reference and then
in 65
my father started to create the
federation
because the demand is growing big and a
lot of people
try to train and so he started creating
rules for a federation for the sport jiu
jitsu
and that's to start the difference
between the color belts because
if you're ten years wide belt you're
gonna be better than a
six months white belt and if it's not
fair for them to compete so let's make a
blue belt
purple belt to create the reference not
only for
practice but for competition because a
new warrior
is not going to be a gold water so let's
make different rankings
and that's what's the process for
callers belts
was the evaluation of levels and stuff
so
with this jiu-jitsu becomes
also a sport jiu-jitsu who has points
mount position throwing
and has the self-defense aspect which
lead you to
a more open-minded situation if somebody
come in with a knife
if two against one if the guy coming to
punch me is
there's no punches in jiu-jitsu so you
start to open your mind to possibilities
for unpredictable situations against a
knife against a punch with
fight with globe fight without so we
start to become a more
open mind so with the
coming to america after especially after
hoy's
kick-ass on the ufc people start to say
wow
what this kid did with the ghee is
so people want to learn jujitsu but they
also want to compete in jiu-jitsu and
competition becomes bigger
than the actual platform for learning
jiu-jitsu with self-defense
the protocols the technical protocols
for
spending technically the jiu-jitsu are
not there
it's just brazilian communists with
experience of fighters
to to experience how to fight and they
come here and display and fight
so in many gracious academies or
brazilian jiu-jitsu academies people
teach how to pass a guard he people
teach how to
choose to choke or to do a foot lock but
they don't teach gun retention
harassment control
knife attacks and and fighting without
gloves
fight striking so because that
lack of information competition
jiu-jitsu becomes much
bigger than the self-defense judges and
now brazilian
anyone can do brazilian jiu-jitsu can
fight
can pass guard can do sweeps
but not anyone knows the total grace in
jiu-jitsu which is self-defense and
more elaborate techniques for
self-defense
like the the law enforcement programs or
situations which
require more techniques so that's
basically today
is a big difference when people refers
gracie jiu-jitsu they go more towards
the traditional aspect of the art
and and when they talking about
brazilian jiu-jitsu they
really recognize as a competition
but they say they are the same with lack
of information you know
in in both sides because sometimes now
you see self-defense academies who have
no fighting skills
they're more like self-defense and the
others
other academies they have fighting
skills but they have zero self-defense
so it's important a movement to bring
those together
for the perfect academy become a center
of knowledge
and practice for competition not only
competition or no
not only self-defense yeah i i don't
know if this is positive for
or negative but i just i just refer to
all of this as jiu jitsu now yes i don't
even i i don't even say brazilian i
don't say gracie
but it's just to me jujitsu is all of it
i
agree and and that's not just me i
should say that's when i talk to
everybody in the jujitsu community they
just say jiu jitsu
so you used to have to say well it's
different this is gracie jiu-jitsu or
this is brazilian juice because you had
japanese jiu jitsu and all these other
things now jiu jitsu is
what your dad made yeah my my federation
is jiu jitsu global federation it's not
bjj
or no self defense racism
yeah do you think that some of the
confusion also comes from
because you have like gracie academy you
have gracie baja you have gracie humaita
and there's so many great like
officially named academies and
places that have gracie in it yes
and your question is if i feel what
do you think that that adds to the
confusion you know
for people so to so we end up how jacob
said we end up
eventually just calling it jiu-jitsu do
you think that that added to the
like the confusion of the the separation
of them
right now the situation becomes very
very uh complex because
the brazilian jiu-jitsu states for
tournaments and competition the gracie's
jujitsu is more traditional
and jiu jitsu embraces everything i
believe
talking about jiu-jitsu is the perfect
way now to deal with the situation
because
it's just jiu-jitsu and and how you
practice will determine
make the determination if you going to
be a mma fighter if you're going to be a
police officer if you're going to be
just a practitioner or if you want to
compete
so all this it gets into the jiu-jitsu
category which i believe now is
from here to the future becomes jiu
jitsu
do you do you find or do you know
anything about like grace
gracie baja comes off as like one that
they focus heavy
heavy on competition yes is that do you
think that that's the case
yes because carlos gracie jr which is
the
president of the ibj jf felt like
marty feeds the tournaments with
students
better for him as a prophet better for
him as a
growing the politics of jiu-jitsu so
he's
emphasizing the the competition element
and creates us a a
a team around that which is very strong
gracie baja
and other teams like allianz or checkmat
or or other teams that they all coming
in that same pattern
so it's very big it's a very good for
the sport yeah so
is there options because that's a lot of
time the question right where it's like
oh
i don't know what to choose and why and
all this they just kind of want to start
but then they hear like oh some
some academy is focused on sport
jiu-jitsu which might
not be aligned with my interest
yes i feel like for every jiu-jitsu
practitioner
today who is blue belt
maybe a hundred give up before get the
blue belt
at least if you put in a perspective
with
jiu-jitsu put you confronting yourself
every time you go to the academy you
have to somehow
put prove yourself show yourself
is like a tough enough resilient enough
capable to to to create strategies so
it's a challenge there
the average jiu-jitsu academy
for every 10 students who come in to try
the jiu-jitsu road
eight will live in less than six months
because somehow it's not only show you
the techniques
i show you the techniques you love it
and then you repeat you love the class
at the end of the class say okay
echo sit uh lay down john
mount john you try to keep your position
echo try to escape
at this point we unleash the wild
yes sir the wild white melts yes and
then
that confrontation can lead to
a little brute movement a little
violence or
you know sometimes the guy is too young
too aggressive
so you're gonna deal with a beast which
you you recognize as your worst
nightmare and you have to basically be
comfortable or say okay the guy kicked
my ass too they are gonna go back there
to me tomorrow gonna fight again
so you have to have within your your
capacity to be resilient to be
tough to be competitive so when you have
this
no matter the road the bumpy road ahead
of you you're gonna get from jiu-jitsu
everything he can give you because you
have
you have the the the balls you have the
courage to go there and
put yourself there to to to learn
some days you're gonna get hurt some
days you're gonna hurt somebody but
that's part of the practice
for 90 of the people they don't have
they get
short on that capacity so they
experience jiu-jitsu and they say hey
man i love jiu-jitsu but it's not for me
i work in computers i'm an artist
you know you guys are tough you can do
for me i'm very gentle i am a doctor i'm
so so they cannot involve in that
practice because
in one point it's not the practice it's
what they have in their hearts you know
it's their courage is their resilience
their capacity to handle pain is compare
so the elements are lacking for if you
lack of those elements
you basically don't find yourself
fitting in any academy of jiu-jitsu
because you have to roll
yes sir my idea of the future for
jiu-jitsu
is to create a level in jiu-jitsu where
you experiment
the essential sensitivities it's a
sensorial jiu-jitsu you start to
breathing
you start to feeling the leverage you
start to feeling the angles you start to
feel your invisible power
you start to feel your connection your
reflexes your defenses
for the sake of knowledge for the sake
of being proof
you have a chance but
at least for the first year of practice
you should not have an opponent
you should have only training partners
this way
you're gonna have a guy who's gonna
experiment jiu-jitsu gonna love the
techniques gonna understand their
strategy
and you're gonna probably gonna lost
weight you're gonna get fit you're gonna
get
you know confident on his knowledge
but not to prove all the time not to be
able to go and and be a fighter or
competitor
this way with the jiu-jitsu we can help
executives you can help anyone
in this in the full circle but if the
jiu-jitsu is traditional competition
is drive you to to do to be an athlete
sometimes you fall short because you
don't want to be an athlete
so the idea of give
something i never ever find somebody who
don't like jiu-jitsu
depends how you will be introduced
depends how your practice is
so you can appeal for the good kid for
the tough kid for the bully for
the for the shy one they all love jiu
jitsu if i don't put for the shy i want
the pressure for him to quit
so he's gonna love to roll he's gonna
have to move he's gonna love to do
for the bully i'm gonna give him not
only the knowledge of jiu-jitsu but i'm
going to put him to compete for him to
start to respect
others and be more mellow in the
attitude
so i can help the bully i can help the
shy one i can have the
the soft one the top they all can learn
but in a different patterns
so what i try to accomplish and and
still in my time in my lifetime is be
able to to create a program
who involves anyone in the family
without
the the this the idea of
prove yourself prove you capable because
when you put that kind of challenge
a lot of people are not going to enjoy
the capacity in the
in the in the development of themselves
i was thinking about it from a surfing
perspective because i know echoes
echo's planning to start surfing if i
said okay welcome to surfing echo
and we took them up to mavericks in half
moon bay
with 20-foot day yeah our pipeline
but maverick's even better though
because it's a whatever 52 degree water
it's freezing cold it's foggy it's dark
and there's sharks
you aren't even gonna go out yeah you
aren't even gonna paddle out
well you're not even gonna pop it out
so so that's like going to first day of
jiu jitsu and there's
you know a 220 pound 21 year old blue
belt that's getting ready to crush
the person that just showed up that
wants to learn yeah in some academies
you're going to have a bad experience in
the first day
and the world and other academies you've
been protected first month or the second
month so you say okay now it's time for
you
one hour class 45 minutes okay now you
guys stop
let's keep rolling guys you guys can
roll you can so you protect somebody
from rolling
for one or two months but in one point
you have to allow him to roll right
and that that that drop off will start
from that point when you
start to understand yourself as having
to roll all the time
and that sometimes can be completely
depressive for many
yes so taking that challenge taking that
compromise to compete
and allowed yourself to go there to
enjoy yourself
is is the is the key for bringing more
people to the benefits of jiu-jitsu
because i see like jiu-jitsu
can help you in a in a huge spectrum
not only help you on the mat but outside
of the match so sometimes
you you you practice jiu-jitsu you
become calm and you become better father
better police officer
it's just for the practice you know so
it's a very important
element of self-confidence build
self-esteem and
and and so on so it's something we all
can do
regardless your as your desire to
compete or to really fight
well i'm glad it's going where it's
going because it seems to keep growing
for sure yes um
you also you know you hear you mentioned
that it not only is horny and trying to
control
all this stuff but he's also got guys
like henzo coming in
who's you know a great teacher you said
uh
you said henzo became a father figure to
his younger brothers half and high and
into many others
by the time he arrived in america he was
already leading many of the younger
gracies
and other friends who lacked direction
henzo was a born fighter
who rather than getting scared in
dangerous situations got focused
henza would go on to be one of the most
successful jiu jitsu teachers
in america meanwhile you had uh
you say the west l.a karate school
rented me their school on pico boulevard
in an industrial section of los angeles
it was a traditional japanese karate
school
complete with raised wooden platform an
oil painting of an old japanese karate
master
hot in the summer and cold in the winter
my school had no sign
no parking no windows no showers and it
was almost impossible to find
i can vouch for that but since i was a
family champion in california was
buzzing about the
about gracie jiu jitsu it did not take
long for dangerous men from all over the
world to
to find this run down karate dojo tucked
away in an alley
next to an auto body shop most of my
first generation of students were
aspiring professional fighters
lifelong martial artists from other
styles surfers
or professional men of action who use
physical force in their daily
occupations
soldiers cops prison guards and bouncers
that's what i mean by dangerous
some wanted to learn while others just
wanted to test their skills against us
but in the end almost all became
dedicated gracie jiu jitsu students
my pico academy was a neutral
environment where you you had to leave
your preconceptions and prejudices
in the locker room i didn't allow it
onto the mats
you certainly did not
uh this i thought this
was interesting because you you say this
about coming to america when we first
came to the u.s kim and i were working
our asses off just to get by while life
on the mat was always the same life off
the mat was more difficult because
america was so different from brazil
like the united states brazil had been a
colony but it was the
it was one where the europeans at first
went primarily to fill their boats with
golden emeralds
and go home in contrast america had been
much more idealistic
had a much more idealistic constitution
and grew into a more orderly
society literally people here did things
i'd never seen before
they stood in line stopped for traffic
lights and mostly obeyed the laws
[Laughter]
these these may seem like obvious
requirements for a workable society
but to me for me it was a strange new
world my transition to living in
american society was not always so
smooth
you got some good stories about some of
the things you went through there
um yeah and it's the same
for for your kids and you say this
moving moving was probably hardest for
hoxin that's your oldest son in a few
short months
he had gone from being the prince of rio
to being just another skinny
hispanic-looking kid in california
public school who didn't speak english
and his being physically small compared
to most of the american kids made him
insecure
all the esl classes in the world can't
help that one morning he came out of his
room to go to school with football
shoulder pads under his shirt
and insisted on wearing them to school i
said no of course but i saw right into
the source of his pain
in an effort to become a leader hoxin
tried to overcompensate with aggression
and become extreme and became extremely
reckless
in order to prove himself he would
accept any challenge and fight anyone
when i sent him to elementary school in
torrance he wanted to fight every kid
there
at least once a month the principal
would call me screaming hochson fought
six kids today he doesn't understand the
rules of basketball and won't let the
other kids have the ball
another time hoxson came home with a
backpack full of candy he told me some
[ __ ] story about how he
found it but i knew he'd stolen it even
my punishing him did little to correct
his behavior
i have been a fighter in my entire life
so i understand putting myself at risk
but hoxson was always putting himself at
risk
in situations that were not rational or
intelligent
this trait had always been with him he
was very
young when he was very young hoxin once
said to his sister i'm either going to
be rich
in prison or dead can you imagine a kid
saying that
he was drawn like a magnet to trouble
that he could easily could have avoided
this imbalance concerned me because it
took hoxen out of a
zone of comfort and put him constantly
on the edge
i was not just watching another
aggressive gracie growing up i was
watching someone with an
unbalanced mental approach to life when
kim tried to reign him in
he became rebellious and defiant toward
her this caused strife between kim and
me because she did not want her kids to
be gracie brawlers
she'd hoped that the move to america
would put them on a different track but
it was too late
hoxson was already on a self-guided
mission to be the greatest gracie of his
generation
reckless yes but forever a fighter
then we get to early 1993.
horian's dream of bringing vale tudo
fighting to america to showcase jiu
jitsu was about to come true
he asked me to meet with him and his
student hollywood director john melius
and told me that they had backers for
the ultimate fighting championships
america's first valet tudo event finally
an opportunity for me to make a name for
myself
in america this was the opportunity that
i had moved to the united states for and
now it was a reality
when horian told me that he wanted our
younger brother hoist to fight in the
first tournament
and keep me as a backup in case he lost
i was disappointed
so there you go the the first ufc yes
you must have thought that you were
going to be the the guy
i i was sure about that you know i was
sure i was the one who represents the
family
and then i don't come with the news
voice will do because if he lost you
came up you come up and back it up and
stuff
i felt a little tricky was a good
situation for her i don't keep things
under control
but i took as it is and help heist to
fight
i i got to backtrack a little bit you
were going at this time you were
teaching up at the
before you had your studio you were
teaching in the torrance garage right
i start i come here rent a house
start teaching my garage under audience
100 students
he sent me a a list of students so
i already fooled full schedule
for for teachings privates in the garage
and then we we left the garage and
opened the first academy
tournaments academy and i was keeping
teaching
private lessons group lessons helping
the whole system of the film
of the academy there were some seals
that came up and trained with you during
that time
yes and um
there was well one of them was a of old
vietnam
seal a little guy and he he i remember
him telling me
he goes oh you gotta try these gracie
guys
and then another one was a was a
wrestler
a college wrestler a champion wrestler
in america and a big guy
who's who's a good friend of mine and
and
apparently you two used to just go
at it yes definitely
yeah i have a very very deep respect
about about
the seals you know because
and i also met steve watkins which was
also a sergeant
at the conorado bay i guess because he
was selecting
people he was training trainer for the
ceo teams
to make the selection like the hell week
and stuff
so i know a little bit about the
preparation about the situations they
they go through to to get graduated as
seo
and i also experience the practice with
them which
emphasizes a lot because when you get
tired you start to get confused you
start to get doubts you start to make
the poor decisions
ceos they get exhausted and they obey
exactly what they hear
so they don't have they don't blink
or they don't ask or they don't have
doubts they just
dare to to go to move forward on the
mission
so if the missions keep holding the knee
they will hold the knee until they pass
out
[Laughter]
so our training with them
sometimes are done at the academy
sometimes they're in different places
sometimes
on the carpet and they're training on
the carpet
and half hour into the training they're
all bleeding blisters and
and they don't even notice and two three
hours
rest for an hour another two three hours
and they go forever
and if you stop the training they they
engage they fight it and you say okay
stop
you jump on the window they will stop
and jump in the wind they there to obey
what they
so i'm very impressed with their focus
their capacity to
to completely fearless completely
no doubts they they believe they they
show what they have to so it's a very
very special
people you know and i also hear from my
student who are trainer there
in some tests for example you have to go
diving in a 200 yard pool
and they say okay you go to the other
corner if you don't make it
don't show it don't put your head up so
whatever you do
get the other hand or stand in the water
and 90 the guys they try to go for air
when they lose the air because no chance
for you to make the other side
so what they want is make you pass out
under the water
constantly say okay i'm going to die
here but i'm not going to put my head
under the water
and when they pass out they take you off
they survive you and that's all cool but
your mindset is there to accept death to
going through death and now no problem
don't put your head out
so this kind of makes one guy
out a thousand a guy who is able to
accomplish so navy seals are guys
completely prepared to do what they
supposed to do they have no
mind problems they focus they is
admirable how they can control their own
emotions and how they can
stay under pressure and be comfortable
and do whatever they have to do
you know no matter if i'm going that
direction with a gun machine
my partner looking backwards with
another gun machine looking my back
so if i start shooting here he cannot
even turn the head
he have to accept i'm take care of my
side so the loyalty the
surrendering the trust the the courage
is through the high ceiling you know
it's just off the roof
so much personal qualities you know
and it's it's impossible to
make a guy like a guy like that can be a
champion can be anything because he
controls his mind in a very special way
the first guy that i trained jiu jitsu
with was a guy named steve bailey
and he he was probably a
a mid-level white belt when i met him
and he was an
oh i thought he was another guy thought
he was 100 years old he was probably
about 40 or something like that but he
had trained with you guys
and yes and i was in his house also yeah
down down here in san diego yes
and he we showed up on deployment over
in guam
and he came and said who here wants to
learn how to fight now i was a brand new
guy i was like hey i want to learn how
to fight
and i also thought to myself maybe i can
teach the old man a little something you
know because i
i'm i'm pretty badass myself i just
graduated from seal training i'm pretty
tough
and there's probably five of us that
that showed up jeff higgs is another one
and
when jeff higgs is a is uh trained with
fabio sanchez
santos black belt and so we showed up
and again i'm thinking what what's this
old man got for me and he just
like i said he was probably a white belt
at the time but
you know he lined us up and just tapped
us all out and then tapped us all out
again and then tapped us all out again
and that was my introduction to jiu
jitsu yes
and then we got hook yeah totally
totally hooked man
totally hooked um yeah i didn't want to
skip over those early days because those
are pretty legendary days inside the
seal teams and it's so interesting
because nobody knew
anything i mean even from that from what
steve bailey
taught me i probably got in i don't know
how many
skirmishes like fights but platoon
fights you know where you're fighting
your friend where you're not gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of them but you're gonna
definitely figure out what's up right i
got into all kinds of those things with
my friends
and just from what steve bailey taught
me like hey this is the
this is the elbow escape this is the
mount this is the rear naked choke
i think i actually just knew the
americana the
rear naked choke and like the arm lock
maybe
what guard was a little bit a little bit
of mount that was like enough
back in those days man you were like
into the world
king of the world yes in a blind land
who has one eye is the king right
and that's kind of going back the book
that's kind of how it was
for for the first ufc oh yes it was
hois fighting against people that had no
comprehension
of jiu jitsu really yeah they coming
from different styles was a
was a was a war of styles you know
kickboxers
sumo wrestlers and and wrestlers
but the wrestlers they have no
submission they have no striking
they are not good completely today you
see wrestlers with great striking skills
great
guard defenses and things you see judo
guys
with striking skills you see striker
guys with jiu-jitsu skills and rest
so it's a mix but before people
represent their own styles you know and
then
becomes a huge difference yeah if you
don't know jujitsu you're dead on the
woods you're dead
i was you say here uh so this is the
first ufc after hoist beat the boxer
without getting hit then made ken
shamrock the fighter who posed the
biggest threat to him tap in less than a
minute
his confidence surfaced in the final
hoy's faced a tall
dead-eyed dutch kickboxer named gerard
gardu gardeaux
and stuck the same winning formula when
hoyce took him down
to the ground and was just about to
choke him gordo
bit hois's ear after the referee after
he freed his ear ahoy's choked him and
when he tapped hoy's kept choking him
and not stop until
the referee pried him off gordo i'll
tell you what's interesting i was
watching this fight the other day
between between hoyce and ken shamrock
and ken shamrock
went to do a foot locker heel hook no
hesitation whatsoever hois
totally saw it disarm
like did the perfect defense to it got
up on top got the
got got the position and so people will
be like oh you know
flocks are new right no he's being being
around yet yeah they've been around
because hoyt's defended that like it was
nothing
yes which is pretty impressive i think
for 1993
yes um
after hoist won the tournament in less
than five minutes of total fighting time
americans were stunned and amazed by the
power and efficiency of gracie jiu jitsu
overnight hoist gracie became the
biggest name in martial arts and gracie
jiu jitsu exploded in popularity
horian thought it was hard to control
the gracies but soon america would be
flooded with non-family members
who represented the good the bad and the
ugly of my family's martial art during
the 1990s an unusual thing happened to
brazilians when they flew
to the u.s some of their belts magically
turned from blue to brown
or even worse from purple to black
and as you just said in the line of the
blind a one-eyed man is king
that was uh that i mean if
the first ufc's were like miraculous
for martial arts yeah i think it was
like an open eye
everybody start to feel something they
never felt before was like this
mix this integration of fights and fight
people fight differently and
engage and they who win so they start to
make up different conclusions about
what they see on the movies you know
like uh
bruce lee's and stuff so they can kick
fight
40 people and nothing happens and they
start to feel like a little different
their reality
is a little different from the striker
than supposed to be
and they start to feel like how
impossible is to not
engage and not have this kind of tight
and once it's tight it's not easy to
separate and
risk a mess if the referee is not there
to create the space
so and then the value of the grappling
becomes
you know people start to get aware of
how dangerous a grappler is when it's
just around your neck you know and they
start to create
better techniques and it's a different
open mind for everybody yeah it's weird
because if you look at a striker and a
grappler
and you don't know anything the striker
kind of appears to be more dangerous
yes because they're hitting and
especially in the movies you hit them
and they fall down and it doesn't
whereas the grapplers like grabbing hold
of me i mean my wife grabs me
that can't be a problem right but the
difference is major
oh yeah
[Laughter]
so now you start looking to uh you start
looking to fight
and you're gonna end up in japan and you
say unlike the ufc the japan open had
gloves in 20-minute rounds
because it was an eight-man tournament
the winner would have to fight three
bouts in one night
i would have to keep an open mind i
couldn't go in with a strategy or plan
because i didn't know
who i'd be who'd be fighting me my
solutions to problems had to be
reflexive and responsive to me
my fights were solemn celebrations and i
wanted my family friends and students to
there to witness the culmination of all
the training all the sacrifice
and all the hard work on the morning of
the japan valet tudo open
i got to the stadium early and took a
long nap in the locker room when i woke
up i thank god for life
and then acknowledged that it was a
perfect day to die
because of my life's mission was
complete i was representing my art and
my family in the ring
my opponent would have to knock me out
or kill me to win for i was never going
to tap
this was not a sport to me it was my
sacred honor
and again i mean people have to buy the
book to read through
the details that you give what it was
like before the fight what you're going
through
and and you detail some of the fights
themselves and it's
fascinating to hear about them from your
perspective that's why people have to
buy the book
but fast forward a little bit and three
sharp outside won the japan open i bowed
the crowd
on the four sides of the ring but did
not smile the samurai did not celebrate
victories and neither would i
why celebrate a victory your next fight
might be your last
battles are not parties win or lose
fights are sacred to me
so this is an interesting uh thing that
unfolds
here um you say when i got back to la i
learned of
that one of japan's most famous pro
wrestlers
no buhiko takata had challenged me
a few weeks after we returned my
representative in japan called me
to tell me that takata was telling the
press that i had not responded to him
because i was afraid to fight
and then a week later takata's protege
yoshi anjo
one of the villains of japanese pro
wrestling had a press conference to
announce that he was traveling to los
angeles
to fight me to the death
when i heard that andrew had said this i
caught i told him to call me when he got
into town
i wasn't going to stress out about it if
anjo came to fight then we'd fight
the japanese promoters and reporters
were always creating dramas and
fanning the flames these kind of threat
these kind of theatrics were the story
of my life by then
i never lost sleep over the barking dogs
and then december 7th comes 1994.
happens yes i was
i mean tranquil as always
at my house and then my instructor
called me from the academy said hickson
has a cop has a couple here japanese
couple who wants to talk to you
immediately i imagine could be the
fighter
i said okay i'll be right there as i'm
going in the car i was taping my
hand a little bit to give me a little
support for the bones
and setting up the camera my son will
film so he was with me in the car
so when i arrived at my school which was
in the alley deep alley
first thing i saw was a van full of
japanese photographers cameras and stuff
so i was getting in i saw the van open
doors
with japanese inside so i get through
getting to my academy and has this tall
guy who is the president of the ufo
the the ufc the the wrestling
association in japan
oh mr grayson nice to meet you i'd like
to come here to
talk to you i said yes uh you said
you i like to invite you for a fight
in japan i said man i told you already
i'm not going to
fight in the ufo because you guys are
not legit you know
no matter if i win or lose in your arena
can be always fixed
so i have no intention to fight in your
arena yeah but you also said mr gracie
you're willing to fight for your honor
for free
he said yes that's what i'm here for i
thought you're gonna fight me but
i saw you not here for fight yeah but
the fighter is here he's in the backyard
he's in the
outside he can come so okay so call him
and as i saw the guy go out to pick up
the the fighter
i said for a student who was in there i
said hey man you stay in the door
let the guy come back let the fighter
come in but don't let the press come in
so keep the press outside okay so the
guy
the guy the president come in the angel
come in
the door was locked and i said
luis get on the waiver please and give
for mr angelo sign
because the waiver is always a good
secure if you get hurt or something it's
a waiver right to everybody signs waiver
here and then the angel look the waiver
with ugly face and talk with japanese
with the guy
and the guy said to me mr gracie you
mean
if you don't sign the waiver you're not
gonna fight
immediately i felt like was a tricky
question because if i say no he has to
sign he said okay
let's leave them so he will leave and he
will talk whatever he says
oh he quit i was here
said no no forget the paper throw this
paper out you
you want to fight without the paper just
you're welcome let's fight without the
paper forget the paper
and then he jump in the ring we start to
bathe each other how big is how big is
andrew
it's about 200 pounds my
my height a little stacky solid
and uh what did what do you think when
you looked at his eyes would
he look like he was surprised that you
accepted this no i felt like
he was he was playing a villain in
wrestling so he has the ugly face the
attitude he don't
he don't flake he don't blink he don't
show
emotions he's just like ready to go you
know i don't know if he was pretending
or if he's for sure but he was ready to
go
and and the all these reporters none of
them came in
no one come in i didn't let nobody come
in because i don't know what's going to
happen
i don't like somebody which is not my
not my friend to to recorded everything
but
but your son recorded it yes so it was
life was
the camera was on so and then the fight
starts
i felt like he wants to punch me i can
feel the difference in the stance and
the way
when you're looking for a position for a
punch when you grappler when you strike
when you want to kick
so depending up approach i can see if
you more like as a kicker if you want a
puncher if you want a grappling
and i felt like he wants to have your
hands on my face you know he wants to
just
solid punch and i did the same thing i
play a little dummy when he came
with the right i i deflected grab him
under the
waist throw him on the floor we fall off
the mat on the
on this hardwood and he got caught like
in a little fancy so he got caught in a
bad position
and i start to punch him punch and he
was
uh turn back he turned back to me
and i was thinking if i put him to sleep
he can wake up and tell whatever he want
to say
so has to be bigger than that has to be
a punishment
his face has to show so i was hitting
him
backwards on his back until he turned
faced me again so i didn't choke him
i wait for him to turn face me again and
then i keep punching and i broke his
nose a lot of blood
and then he turned back again and i put
him to sleep finally i could
make the tank and make it happen so i
put him to sleep
and he was passing out facing down on
the mat
so when his was out i tell the guys okay
now
the press can come so when the press
come into the the place
start to picture everything he was
already standing up and the guy tried to
cover his face
with his he's hugging him like
protecting his face from the
photographers
and then kim said so
show his face so the guy move out and
the guy's taking pictures of the guy all
bloody
and uh and they left
two days later andrew came back to my
school
with a gift with a samurai helmet and
said
was dishonorable what he did was a lack
of respect but he's apologizing he
want to say he has no problems he was
very very you know straightforward give
me the gift and said he's respect me and
left
and then one week after he states in
japan he was jumped
into the in the fight they jumped me
they
so it's like a villain he talked one
face with me
other face in japan and at this point i
have a tape fortunately so my guy coming
through here
to us i give the tape to him he was able
to show the tape to the press in japan
no make no copies
and bring it back to me i said no make
no no no copies messages
so he showed it for the present so my
name in japan was even bigger because
everything andrew said was a lie and was
proved wrong
and uh so that's happened and and then
eventually
i fought one more time in japan and then
after i fought noburico takada which was
the
the boss of that association in a big
event in tokyo dome
70 000 people sold out arena was a huge
event
that was against takata who was he was
like uh
yoji's uh master right yeah he was the
number one of the
the the wrestling i think andrew was
better than takada as a fighter
he come in with a better fighting
background but he was the villain he
always never going to be the number one
you know
takada has a better pretty look has more
like he's appeals more for the audience
so he was the good guy who always wins
in the end in a fixed fight you can
arrange that with no problems
man that video is still not released
now only for friends so you're going to
be
one for sure going to see a copy yeah
i've been waiting to see that for a long
time
meanwhile there's still life going on
outside of fighting so you got all this
stuff going on
and i i pulled this one out it says one
day a policeman
who knew me called and said i have hawks
in here we caught him trying to steal
from a store
you need to come down when i arrived my
son was sitting on the curb
hixson i'm not going to take him in the
cop said but talk to him he could have
gotten into some serious trouble
when i lectured hawkson on the drive
home about how it was wrong to steal
that he didn't need to do it in order to
prove his worth
he remained silent and stared at his
feet when we got home i said go to the
garage i'm not finished talking to you
he looked me dead in the eyes and
groaned dad can't you just hit me
i'd rather you do that than more talking
we don't need to talk anymore just give
me my punishment
i thought [ __ ] what am i gonna do to
make him fear the consequences of his
actions
that was when i realized i was losing
control of my son hoxson reminded me of
my brother holes
in that they both possessed psychologies
that made me uncomfortable
but while this worried me i figured that
it was a phase he would pass through
as i had
when i returned to japan in 1995 a few
weeks before the tournament i went to
yuri
nakamura's mountain cabin my pre-flight
routine was the same
and again this is all stuff that you
detail
you talk about you know what you're
thinking about psychologically it's so
interesting to read the book and get
that side of the
the fight that's why people got to get
the book
um you have these these fights that you
talk about
uh you you hurt your neck a little bit
then you submit a couple guys you end up
in that classic fight against yuki
nakai yes who had had is i
gouged in his first fight against gordo
yes
and he ended up becoming blind in that
eye because of that eye gouging
yes and he was he's also yuki nikai is a
small little guy
yes he's a brave warrior for sure i have
a lot of respect for the guy
but you went out and it's clear when you
watch that fight i remember watching it
actually
that you went out and basically didn't
do any further damage to the guy
yes than you had my my friends my my
guys and
the practice and the in the locker room
they said you have to kill him
punch him start to damage him whatever
you have a chance you
said no man i'm not gonna do anything
i'm better technician than him i'm
bigger than him i don't have to be hurt
him he's already hurt i mean why are you
going to be
just mean by going to win him
with techniques so i went to the
ring commit to do my thing and prove
myself
i can win without the brutality without
the fear
the aggressiveness which are no need for
that so i was calmly
putting him in uncomfortable situations
until you get the choke
and this plays a very important role
because i always admire japan
i always felt like i leave my personal
bushid which is my moral code my
my code of warrior and uh
and i never knew details about japan
very details but i know
i after that the fact i use white
it represents a lot for them because the
sunride dress is white before the armor
you know in terms of surrender is
a beautiful war color the white i didn't
know that
the fact i'm not celebrating fights
it's the same thing then samurai samurai
are not going to be fighting because he
kills somebody next week next day can be
him so
the fighting is just a a way to go away
of
life which cannot be celebrated at like
a party or
so so the japanese also noticed this
because in the in japan different than
u.s or different places
when the fight starts you don't see
nothing you don't hear anything
the crowd is all quiet and when you do a
move they all oh
they follow the fight with precision
with details
they admire not only the fight but also
the personality how they can relate to
you
your attitude your character
so when i'm not celebrating yuki nakai's
defeat show some respect
show some attitude and the fact i was
not mean to him also they notice
they say hickson didn't punch the guy
they're supposed to
so they noticed the fact i was nice
i was serious for
battle but not overpowering not trying
to be a coward
and and hit him or hurt him in a bad way
so all those little details add to my my
profile in japan because they notice all
those details and they feel like
i was the expression of a new samurai
you know because i was not
bringing back to japan like i thank you
them
for because at the first tournament i
said i'd like to thank you japan to
bring in jiu-jitsu to brazil
and now i'm bringing back because i feel
like
is my way to give back to japan
so all this translates in me become
some kind of expression of what samurai
is supposed to be today
you know japan has a big problem with
secure state of mind because once they
lost the war
the kindness becomes some kind of fear
so
they smell they smile at you they bow to
you but sometimes they don't like you at
all
and they show that kind of code
image of respect of
but eventually they becomes your enemies
they
so japanese lost their soul when they
lost the war
the attitude of samurais proud and so
they lost their source they lost their
attitude so they become more like
servers and and complying with the
energy of the the rest of the
the universe so
my image brought somehow some kind of
example of how the
the modern summer i supposed to act no
swords but attitude the way i speak
the way you know sometimes they prior to
the fights they have like a day a press
day
and then we have 30 different magazines
for 20 minutes interviews
always coming in the in the room and
doing
quick interviews some pictures and they
live so some guys coming from very
important magazines
one of them coming to me and said mr
grace i just have one question
how you do to fight a polar bear
i did not laugh on that question i don't
say anything i just thought what the
question is that
and i answered to him without losing my
my pace i said man
i never intend to fight a polar bear
it's not my
my goal but if i have to fight one i'm
going to have a nice jacket for the
winter i'm going to have a lot of meat
a bare meat on my fridge and i'm going
to have a nice necklace
of bare tooths so with that answer i
show him i'm not afraid
of the outcome i don't blink in front
of my f so it's oh my i not expect
anything like that
i'm sorry they left so just to see how
his mind works
japanese is very special in terms of
uh they have a somewhat helmet almost
like a scent on the altar
you know they have the katanas like
example the god for them comes from like
a
a bushido life of type have to have
honor and dignity integrity
so when they see me they see me like
as a new samurai they bring the kids say
can you touch
touch his face please can you touch his
head things like you don't believe
happens and you say okay sure
[Laughter]
so japanese becomes a very much
enlightened with my
my knowledge of martial arts my my ideas
of
how to deal with my opponents how to
deal with my peace of mind
emotional control and so on so was
uh was something very interesting my
experiences in japan
now that's that's a little bit correct
me if i'm wrong but
in the movie choke right when you're
dealing with this you you know you have
yuki nakai coming up
and you're you're basically telling
hoiler hey listen i'm not going to hit
him
you know i'm going to be p i'm going to
be as do as little damage as i can
and euler's like [ __ ] that you need to
kill that [ __ ] he's going to be
trying to kill you
it's a really good contrast but you you
were able to overcome that and maintain
that
that samurai spirit yes i mean oil is a
great guy he's very tough
and because he was not too big all his
life he was a smaller guy so people
they disrespect while in a different way
than disrespect me
it's forget jujitsu forget gracie family
but they look at me they don't
have problems with me they look at her
and say hey man get out of the pla
so they have no respect so hoyt is
always on his toes
letting nothing pass because he's a
warrior
and he don't want to be disrespected so
any glimpse of
lack of respect he becomes agitated
so one day we left the academy to surf
surfboards on top traffic in brazil
traffic jam and somehow i cut off
a tax driver i make a mistake
and then he he get on my side
and he called me names
and i immediately said hey man i'm sorry
brother sorry bro
and then holly look at you mr hickson
the guy call you this this and that
how you can apologize for the guy why
you don't kick his ass
i said hoiler can you imagine the hell
this guy living
just being on traffic crazy like that
can you imagine we're going to surf now
can you imagine just coming from the
school training sparring kicking ass
training hard you think i'm gonna fight
this guy
he's old he's fat he's out of shape just
to
because he called me a name i have to
beat him up come on holler
forgive this guy let him go let his let
let life
beat him he's already a poor guy
and hoyler told me up today said hickson
that message for me was
hit me on the heart because nothing can
be more
you know i never expect this from you
and once you tell me that i start to
redo my life and see how much people i
can forgive and how much calm i can be
if i don't have to prove i know i can
beat the guy but i don't have to just
prove every time
just because you asked me for and that's
kind of message highly never forgot
anymore
so you end up you you end up fighting
takata once
and then you fight him again um
you beat him i think you beat him by
armlock both times yeah both times
that's why as they say hixson by armlock
going back to the book here
this is 2000 earlier that year hawson
injured his knee while training
it was slow to heal and i think he felt
his dream of becoming a champion fighter
slipping away
while i was in rio there were rumors
going around that hoxon was a
prospective member of an
la street gang by the time i returned to
los angeles hawkson was getting ready to
leave for new york with his brazilian
girlfriend
after hoxin left for the east coast
i received a message from him that he
had made it to new york and that
everything was going well
when we didn't hear from him for over a
month i wasn't worried because he was
still using his atm card in new york
city
a month later december turned into
january
and we still had not heard from him
now i was truly worried my cousin
henzo's academy was in new york city
and some of his students were policemen
so i asked henzo if he could try to find
my son
a few days later a sheik and henzo
called
and told me that an officer had found a
photograph of an unidentified corpse
at the coroner's office with a tattoo
that read
hicks and gracie
number one dad
up to this point hoxson had been a
missing person
this was the confirmation that he was
gone
after i hung up the phone the whole
family melted into tears
seeded beside me looked hopeless
i told the kids that hoxson had moved on
to another life
and was now with holes
now representing the gracie family i had
to go to new york city
for the physical confirmation
i knew in my heart that my son was dead
you talking this um you know in this
section
here i mean obviously i don't i don't
think there's anybody that
that thinks there's anything worse than
losing a child
and you talk about what you did what you
thought
and how you had to get through this
yes um
some some of the some of the lessons
that you had to learn and some of the
things that you
you had to do you know you ended up um
you ended up building like a like a like
a
tree a tree house yes kind of platform
on the tree
and that was sort of your your escape
but it was an escape but it ended up
sort of being a reconnection
definitely i felt like up to that point
my life was being just a
a very beautiful ride you know even with
the pressures even with
the the doubts i have always
been in charge of my own desires i was
thinking i was controlling time
i have a perfect family kids loving
friends and and and trainee i mean
my life was perfect and i was thinking i
was in charge
when hawks on departure i felt like the
the floor just got out of my feet i was
just lost track of
i lose the desire to serve i lose the
desire to train to teach
you know i was a little unsocial a
little bit
you know i i was not saving tears i was
crying a lot
i was i let myself get down to the hole
in a way to embrace a rock and go to the
lake and go deep on the
on the bottom of the lake and i allowed
myself to get deeper enough
to know to feel important
and also from that lower point
decide if i want to kill myself if i
want to drink
drugs give up from like i don't know i
was
just allowed myself to get weak enough
and fragile enough to
from that point see what's happened
and once i get to that bottom
i i decided to make i was in the in the
side hillside on my house i was there
just
and i was climbing some trees and then i
saw a beautiful tree with
a beautiful ocean view said i want to
buy
i want to create a platform here to talk
with oxen
so for about three weeks
from first light on this first light to
down to dawn i was working on this
project
from designing to buying the wood to
buying the
the screws and then bringing the
electrical to make the holes and stuff
and
just focus on this my hands are kind of
bleeding so much work and
so i'm making focus on creating that
kind of platform
and after that platform done
took me almost three weeks
i would make amazing job put the wood
and put
varnish so it was beautiful i felt like
was a mission accomplished there i said
now i make my
tribute to you so i want to be in peace
and it was a better feeling for me to
make this because i
anytime i miss hawks and i was going up
there
light up an incense meditate a little
bit thinking about good things have a
picture
there and i spend
maybe a year more in a much better
vibration but not exactly out of the
hole
and one day i was thinking up there
and i remember what my dad said about
nothing can be a hundred percent wrong
or bad
nothing can be 100 right or good it's
always a dual aspect in everything
and i started thinking what's going to
be the advantage of hawke's departure
how i mean how this can be good in any
way i started looking for a reason
and i and then i i i find
something very important which was
up up to hawks departure i was in charge
if him or anyone else something hicks
can you teach me today
dad can you take me to the beach
whatever it is i can say no
not today let's go tomorrow let's leave
this not today i'm gonna feel good i
wanna
so i was thinking about being in charge
of the time in a much more
powerful way than i was than i have
so after his departure i'm sure
tomorrow may never happen
so based on that difference i start to
use in my day much more efficiently
to give you an example i could be down
on the freeway to
to fight in japan or to make a big
program in japan
i'm in the freeway if my daughter called
me dad i have to talk to you
she's crying i will stop the car in the
freeway
and talk to her what's the problem ah
this and that so has all the
resolve this so i will talk to her until
i be able to give my best
opinion my best information give my time
as long as it takes
after this finish i turn off the phone
i will see if i still have time to go to
japan if i still have time to get the
flight whatever if not
i will reschedule i will do because
today
i have i cannot do this for tomorrow
so i learn effectively how to use my
time
with precision with with not exp
wasting time with things are not matter
or not give you the value of time
which time is very valuable and i start
to become more effective on how to use
my time
how how the purpose of my life my
service
what is really matters for me and i
started using my day much more
worth it from a conversation like that
today
from a teaching a student from talking
with my family
i will be much more precise i would be i
want to be much more on time
much more you know with no
loose ends or no no gaps it's just tight
so by doing that i reborn
i i reinvent myself in a different me
with much more compassion much more
interested for things
much more ways to to to bring jiu-jitsu
to others
i'm still at service so being
happy with that make me feel like i have
to thank you hawkson for his departure
in order for me to achieve that kind of
enlightenment that kind of
depth on my being alive and being at
service
if i was not for that i could be a lot
of loose gaps up today and having my
mind in a different
manner so i saw the positiveness of his
departure have
given me the chance to become a better
man so i'm thankful
in a way he's taught me that with his
departure so
i compensate a little bit and from that
on i become
fully restored my energy levels my
happiness my this
my my desire to to live my life and let
hawks on
be in peace in in heaven and with you
know with halls and waiting for us
dancing and being happy
yeah that's um i've i've
had that conversation with myself uh
quite a few times
you know i've lost some very close
people to me and i've i've actually had
that
discussion with many other people um as
they
lose lose their loved ones and
you know they will people have literally
asked me you know what possibly
what possible good can there be from
this there's nothing good this is
horrible
and like you did you have to kind of
pull back
and and look at things from a different
perspective and and they're
there always is something positive there
always is a lesson to be learned there
always is the memories that you
that you get to keep yes
um and obviously this this had an impact
on the rest of your family you you say
here
losing hoxin put kron on the path to
martial arts greatness
on some level i think hoxton knew that
kron had the natural talent and tools to
be even better than he
like all my kids he had trained jiu
jitsu all of his life but was never
inter
as interested as hoxin now it was his
turn to shine
even though they were brothers hoxin and
crone were completely different hoxson
was emotional intense and intent on
proving himself
a gracie warrior kron was more observant
analytical and calm
he wanted to do the right things and
always be at his best
in one of their last conversations hoxin
told cron
that he was a gracie and to give 110
and never quit in whatever it was that
he chose to do
after hawkson died kron took that to
heart and was now on a mission
to become the next apex predator in the
gracie food chain
you say here the the more kron won the
less attached he became to winning
after he realized that the outcome of
fight does not define you as a person he
improved by leaps and bounds
he trained as hard as humanly possible
and when he competed he let the chips
fall where they may
win loser draw he would be back in the
academy on monday
and train as if the fight had never
happened
when my father died in his sleep in 2009
at the age of 95 i was in europe with
kron for the
european jiu jitsu championship we
received the news
the day of the tournament and knew that
we could not get back to brazil for the
funeral
instead we went back to our hotel room
and held our own memorial
we cried and shared memories the day
elio died kron represented his
grandfather on the mat as elia would
have liked
he won both of his matches by submission
and after he won the european title
he kissed the picture of hoxin that
always as always and bowed to the giant
mural of elio
the tournament organizers put up to come
commemorate his life
it was a beautiful moment for both of us
alio and carlos gracie's
legacies were now being carried and
upheld
by a third generation
that's the family tradition huh
um again you know in the book you you
carry on and
and and talk about um you know some of
some of the other things that proceeded
after that
and i wanna i wanna get a little bit go
towards the end of the book here
um and you know you've talked about this
a little bit today
but i think it's important to reiterate
you say my goal today
is to create a form of jiu-jitsu that
will empower the entire person
both on and off the mat if i can ever
make a nervous person feel more relaxed
than they've ever felt before
i'm changing them from within in a way
that a psychiatrist or a pill
never can
today conflict comes in many forms and
physicality is only one aspect of it
conflict follows humans wherever they go
and people adopt different strategies to
cope with it
modern enemies can strike in a text an
email or in a social media post
as the world of instant communication
has evolved many negative unintended
consequences have evolved with it
50 years ago a 10 year old boy went in
his room only to sleep
because he spent all day outside playing
today if parents aren't careful their
children will spend the entire day
alone in their rooms we cannot dismiss
technology but why let us turn us into
brains with veg vegetable bodies
one of the worst side effects of
technology is the way it is reduced
human direct interaction because people
can get almost everything they desire
food
entertainment friendship sex via the
screen they have gotten to the point
of being scared of face-to-face
interaction there are so many wonderful
things that are impossible to experience
on a screen
jumping into a cold river making the
drop on a big wave
and walking in the rain or just a few
even worse social media provides an
arena
arena for cowards to lurk in the cyber
shadows and say things that they would
never dare say in person
mike tyson put it best when he said that
social media has made people quote
way too comfortable with disrespecting
people and not getting punched in the
face for it
today i try to use jiu-jitsu as a tool
to teach patients
hope strategy emotional control
breathing and many other things all
without conflict and competition
this allows those who need it most to
learn the visible
and invisible aspects of the art in ways
that could help them in their everyday
lives
i have developed a training routine
wherein students learn
the practice learn and practice all the
movements and techniques of jujitsu in a
cooperative instead of competitive
environment
i can teach the most critical invisible
aspects of jiu-jitsu
like base timing weight distribution and
connection with little stress
in this type of class i can have two
beginners blocking punches and doing hip
throws
your training partner is there to help
not to fight you
so that's what you were talking about
earlier today yes
i felt like
we all in warfare is not about
being a soldier is not about being a
fighter
we are under stress we are you know our
lives today
are driving in different modes and
different aspects
so what you really need to conquer
is happiness your biggest
achievement is to focus on how you how
to be happy how to bring your family
to the best scenario how to bring your
job how to bring your
your assets how to bring your your
uh the way you practice your physical
so you want to conquer a lot of things a
lot of things should be conquered in
order for you to be
happy and in order for you to
be happy he's not lucky i don't believe
in luck
i don't believe you you you're gonna be
happy just by close your eyes
you know and if you're happy today
ten years from now what make you happy
today either evolve
or doesn't make no no sense it's not
gonna make you happy
you have a different goals every every
time you just have a different
first buy a car then buy a house then
get married whatever it is
is next step to make you happier to make
you in a good position
and i see those kind of challenges those
kind of obstacles
as little battles which
when you focus when you have the
capacity
strategical capacity when you have
emotional control when you have
believe in yourself when you have hope
so a lot of elements on the water
toolbox
has to be used for daily practice
for average joes it's not about being
a special warrior and be able to have
emotional control
it's for the weak ones for the guy who
has an email and gonna lose
his rent or whatever so this guy needs
emotional control it's the same i need
the same you need you know so the idea
of
empower people cannot come in with
i will empower you but you have to prove
you can handle
sometimes that i don't have i don't have
what it needs i don't have what it needs
to
to be a fighter but he loves to learn
details for self defense he loves to
learn details for self-emotional control
through breathing
he loves understand what's the solution
for that
for that problem what's the solution for
that so based on information based on
practice he may never fight nobody
but that's will incorporate on his
behavior a completely different
mindset a completely different way to
breed and
and and rebalance the stress a complete
different way for you to feel good
about a possible engagement
so sometimes i train in my students
to keep the distance not in hey not in
not clinch but keep just
stay away from my punch so i will try to
so based on your
space you can survive you see people in
the ufc
surviving an attack basically moving
away
so if you just move away you don't have
to be a fighter
to survive so i i put my expert in not
getting punched
that's already a a big asset in your
life if you average joe
you make sure you're nobody going to
punch you in the face so it's a big win
already
so my purpose with that knowledge is to
prepare
people to win without a fight
based on different components mental
components
spiritual components and physical
okay man you don't have to prove me you
just have to believe you have a chance
so
by giving that chance for average joe
i want to empower the world in a
different and a very special way because
i will offer them what they need
to become more humanized to become more
sharp to become better
in control to become more strategically
correct what makes
life different if you tell me what the
successful people has in common
all the successful people have few
things in common
they all love what they do
they're all capable to to to to to pass
obstacles and not give up easy
they all capable also to
to to become
to making decisions under pressure
they're all able to
keep learning and keep progressing keep
it take advan
so they have open mind about how to
strategize how's the new game coming
so they're not they're not unfamiliar
with
with behaviors and situations which
everybody's successful has in common
so give you those tools give you the
glimpse of
what you need to become successful if
you have to believe in what you do you
have to
to practice you have to make sure the
strategy is correct and so on so based
on those elements
i cannot transform people from a coward
guy to make him a courageous
but i can make a coward guy becomes
talent enough to believe he has a chance
and that's can transform his decisions
and a courageous decisions
so because we live in a life of
pretending because we live in a life of
images and look good and
so i like to take you from
you looking from the mirror before you
start you feeling
so when you start to feel yourself in
that
you start to understand your breathing
understand your leverage understand your
base
completely change the dynamic you handle
the word the way you shake your hand the
way
you approach somebody looking in the eye
and things like that so
that kind of jiu-jitsu can favors anyone
in the globe
different than a specialized jiu-jitsu
for competition
which favors just the warriors who want
to favor
true jiu-jitsu yeah that's
uh you know you were talking about what
does successful people have in common
they got they can
they have an open mind they overcome
obstacles
they use the right strategies at the
right times
they're comfortable in these
uncomfortable positions and situations
and
these are all things that you can learn
if you learn jiu jitsu yes
of course because a meta form for life
you know
this is the same situation you have to
be calm enough and breathe and put your
hand
and start working leverage instead
brutality
same thing in life you get any any any
problems you have to have the same
articulated mindset to just
survive or escape or or control whatever
it is it's all about
making quick changes and start to become
focused and
the purpose
you know i'm going to read one last
little section from the book we're
almost at
what we are three hours right now so i'm
going to want read one little
last section from the book goes fast
when we enjoy
it does i could sit here all day
you say this on my best day now i'm only
five percent of what i once was as a
fighter
however my invisible power transcends my
physicality
and will be part of me until the day i
die
that is why for me jiu jitsu is about
much more than fighting
it is a tool to teach people about
themselves
it is great to see it become so popular
and provide lucrative businesses for so
many
but this has nothing to do with what i
teach of my students 98
trained two or three days a week trying
to perfect basic techniques
and then testing them on a level playing
field
helping my students try to become better
people
not just smashing machines is what
motivates me
jiu jitsu is my philosophy my sacred
honor
and my family tradition it has made me
strong enough
to forgive and confident enough
to fight for my beliefs
just uh just outstanding um
jiu jitsu is life yes
so before you before you go um once
again this book is called breathe
a life in flow it's by hicks and gracie
with peter mcguire who's
actually become a friend of mine and i
know he's a friend of yours and
a great guy a surfer a jiu jitsu
practitioner
yes a a scholar
yes so i look forward to working with
him some more
um so the way that you're spreading the
word now
you have hixson.academy yes
that's where you do online training
i watch some of the videos you're gonna
get people
are gonna get such good details out of
what you're saying
um sometimes i think it'd be impossible
for someone to explain how you
put pressure and how you how you
stabilize hips and how you move hips and
but when you watch those videos you
start to understand
you do have the ability to explain what
you're doing
yes because jiu-jitsu is about feeling
it's not about seeing or understanding
you have to feel
and i like to approach jiu-jitsu in
i have to make you feel when you relax
when you just about angles just about
details invisible details who translates
in a deep effectiveness so
i don't start to seeking to you show me
what you have
i try to make you i try to take you off
your elements okay relax
and put you in a way for you to
understand and feel
the week's vision the vision of the weak
one
into the approach because if you feel
like you can fight as a weak person
imagine if you put the muscles you have
on
if i turn if i change around and start
you using exporting the muscles you have
on
you may never gonna perceive the the
depth of what i want to show you
so my father always say when he's
training somebody said hey man stop stop
you too dance be relaxed loosen up if
i'm not i cannot fight
because he was just seeking to give you
the information which
goes into your gut feeling you say wow i
never felt like that
difference can change so much and
effectiveness
and by feeling that you start to feel
like it's a different
element to be added to whatever you have
if you're strong if you're fast if you
if you compare all this are qualities
personal qualities but the
the the depth of the knowledge we try to
pass to you
transcends all this so you're able to
not only explain for a weak person but
to also to
in case somebody with 300 pounds solid
muscle can
you have the chance to deal with them in
a different natural comfortable
situation so
it's amazing how much that kind of
sensorial feeling
can add to your capacity to
mental capacity to your spiritual
capacity and to also to your physicality
so that's that's hixon academy hicks and
dot academy
is how you get there um great stuff on
there you have
you have hixsonggracy.com it's sort of
where you can
uh buy you can read some history stuff
but you got a store on there
uh and then on facebook you're hixing at
hicks and gracie
and on instagram which you have a bunch
of cool little clips on instagram too
and that's uh hicks and gracie jj
yes echo you got anything
i have many things but in the sake of in
the spirit of saving some time
i have one question so you know what uh
the first ufc one nature when horian
chose
hois yes did he did he tell you why he
chose hoist rather than you
yeah his answer was i want to put voice
because
in case something happened with him we
always have a better
a big a bigger bullet to put it on so
but in reality was he has control over
voice did
he did have control over me i was
already working on pico boulevard
i was already my own you know have my
own school
okay so in order for him to have control
of
of of not only the fighter in there
but still with the best brand was better
for him to have voice
gotcha they they said that um
i think might have been like in the
documentary or whatever they were like
he wanted to kind of display jiu-jitsu
with someone who was like uh less
physical less
you know big or whatever that way it
would display jiu jitsu a little bit
better because like if you went in
and you're like this more athletic guy
they were like oh well he's more of an
athlete so it doesn't really
highlight the jiu jitsu part of it yeah
i disagree
with that because for me and between me
and him are only 10 pounds difference
so i felt like he was
able to even even the first payment for
for the ufc
he hold i supposed to get a 50 000 check
and i supposed to get 5 000 from oysters
i still waiting because he didn't pay
voice he didn't pay
hoist didn't pay me so
was just pure love for us and he was a
businessman so he knows better what he's
doing so
i kind of disagree with that statement
if he heist was smaller and look
fragile i swear stuff too i've trained
with voice
he's not small and he's not fragile
that's for damn sure
yeah yes thank you pleasure brother
hicks and any closing thoughts man first
thank you
you are such an inspiring warrior and
having
you know you helping me on the book and
and
get me on your podcast is already a
blast
second man i feel like we are in the
same business of empowerment
you know you you bringing your knowledge
your expertise to help people in terms
of
understand pressure understand
discomfort to understand victory
understand
you know bravery and i'm in the same
business
which empowers people and give them
better chances to handle life
which is not easy those days so it's a
pleasure to talk to you it's a pleasure
to see the energy which is
similar and we are in the same mode of
supporting the future generations you
know with your expertise
with my expertise so it's just a great
day on the office and
happy to say you know this book maybe
help a lot of people
and this book is just the idea my is my
personal life
is not something which has the intention
to
make you copy or or be what what is in
the book
but create something creates a venue for
different discussions
creates a venue for different seminars
different speeches and
and everything coming from that because
in essence
we all need to use more love in our
hearts we all need to use
more techniques to
victory you know nothing comes for lucky
nothing is just
uh act of god i feel like you have to
represent yourself
in terms of have god be inside you and
bringing the best service to make people
get beneficial benefits from it so
thank you chu well uh thank you
thanks to your whole family uh i guess
especially your uncle
and and to your father yes uh who
created this incredible martial art
brought it to the world
and and like you've been saying it's not
just it's not just to
help people fight better but actually to
live better
and it's had such a huge impact on my
life and i i
i can say without hesitation that
my life would not be even close to where
it is
if it wasn't for you for your family and
for jiu jitsu so
it's an honor to know you it's an honor
to talk to you and i will continue to do
my best to spread the art
that your family and you taught to me
thank you my brother thank you echo
thank you perfect
thank you appreciate it thank you and
with that
hicks and gracie has left the building
only after he did spend a few minutes
talking about invisible jiu-jitsu
and you know showing me some stuff
yeah were you you you were hit did you
hit recorder were you
you videoed a little that a little bit
yeah yeah
it's weird he so he talks about this
thing called invisible jiu-jitsu which
we didn't really talk about today
but it's a thing and i know it's a thing
because
you know when you're showing a move like
let's say i'm showing a move with you
and i'm talking to so i'm using you as a
dummy
and i'm talking to the group of students
right
and i say well you can't really see what
i'm doing here
to the students but i'm like echo do you
feel this and i
it feels one way and then i go now feel
this and no one can tell anything
different but you go yeah it feels a lot
heavier it feels a lot
like i'm off balance or feels a lot more
stable so there's things in jiu jitsu
that are invisible and obviously the
hardest thing to teach well hixson
that's sort of hixson's
thing yeah is he's got the these things
that you cannot see
but they're real they're invisible but
they're real and
and like i was trying to explain he
talks about some of those on on hickson
dot academy he starts to go into details
of those things and he can explain it
yeah so and just when he was explaining
it to me and
[ __ ] and i will say you know he's doing
it to me and i'm like well that
is freaking awesome yeah right yeah
and jiu-jitsu is so dynamic even if you
don't see it
where doing it versus not doing it
is night and day when you're in there
you know so like even like the
the thing was where you you're
essentially controlling your base
right you controlling your base versus
not controlling your base in that way
when you go up against somebody and they
have to contend with you controlling
your base in that way versus not is
going to be a completely different
scenario for them different experiences
when i grabbed the single on him
yeah and he was like you know go ahead
and i started like trying to get a
little
little uppity with that thing and i
couldn't move him
and i was you know i'm starting to think
i'm
i i'm actually i mean we did it for 20
seconds right and i in my mind i was
like i'm working right now
that's what i was thinking i was like
i'm working i'm trying to pull this
thing and he's not working
he's just he's just using invisible
jiu-jitsu versus me
and it's it's gonna wear me out oh yeah
and you can't even see it
but you before you came in when he
started he you could see he kind of
wanted to show me some
stuff and he goes he goes stand here
and you know start with it
and um he's just like stand here and he
started doing like some basic
self-defense with me and i was like okay
you know cool
you know i'm thinking of course what am
i thinking i'm arrogant i have a big ego
right i gotta know this and he goes okay
now do this and i was like okay
and he's basically he pushes me and i
like immediately get my base right you
know my put my foot back again into a
fight stance
he goes okay well that's okay right
and he says now do this and he teaches
me a little invisible jitsu and he now
he pushes me again and i don't go
anywhere
right that's the jiu jitsu
so awesome to have hixon on uh
speaking of jiu jitsu we're training jiu
jitsu if you're not training jiu jitsu
obviously start training jiu jitsu
and when you do that guess what you're
going to need supplements
oh look at you yeah yeah it does
rock and roll it does help he did talk
about two
uh actually i'm not even sure if he
talked
about it on air where you know when you
a lot of people start jiu jitsu and then
they they stop jiu jit then they stop
because in one of the elements one of
them is
that they jump into the competitive
part of it go to war yeah the war and
not even necessarily voluntarily like
they'll get they'll get
thrown oh yeah we're sparring right now
ghost just go spar and then they'll come
across someone who's
you know intense or whatever and a lot
of times you just become intense just
because of the unfamiliar nature with
what you're doing because you're a human
being it's being escalated on and you're
going to escalate back
and the ego and the whole nine yards you
know it's level seven war
yeah and then just but just even before
it gets toward just that stress
it's like some people they don't want
that beef right away yeah
even if some people they don't want that
beef they just they want to learn they
want to learn and you know
have kind of a stress-free learning kind
of experience
but that's part that's part i never
really thought about you know because i
think we kind of go in
down for that beef you know i i
mentioned
surfing as a comparison i'm like hey if
you're going to start surfing and i take
you to
mavericks yeah which is scary
rocks cold water sharks
giant waves you're not even gonna get in
the water bro yeah you're literally not
gonna get in the water
and i think that's the way a lot of
people unfortunately view jiu-jitsu
and they're kind of right because if you
go to a lot of schools guess what's
happening day one you're in the big
water in the deep water in the cold
water with sharks
yeah and you're getting bit just kind of
left yeah you know
it's a so that man i
i wish i would think about that a little
bit more yeah it's definitely something
to think about
but it is good form of exercise which is
important exercise in all capacities
very important and yes we do need
supplementation from time to time i
think if it's part of your routine
you're gonna be you're gonna reap way
more benefits over time
short and long long term by the way so
jocko supplements are
jocko fuel let's start with the energy
drinks and that's what it is
discipline go real energy yep had one
today by the way
actually i've been having one currently
kind of down right now
pretty much every day mm-hmm you don't
have to drink one every day but
that's just happened since whatever you
can yeah
some new flavors out watermelon and
mango passion fruit
mango passion fruit's the best flavor
according to some people yeah
well factually i think i'm pretty sure
if actually
is the best flavor so yeah if you're not
if you didn't uh
know that travis mills might have
something to say about that you know i
yeah i would expect that to be the case
he might he might have to open a can of
what basketball is
watermelon i anticipate that being the
case yes nonetheless he has new flavors
so yes chuck check those out let me know
what you think
the mango one good reviews so far anyway
yes healthy energy drinks that's echo's
thing that's echoes flavor by the way so
everybody knows
all good it's not a bi it's it's not an
unbiased judgment
it's his flavor his signature flavor
like i said factual nonetheless all
healthy
all good no bad drink a bunch of them
and you'll be bet literally better off
be a better be a better person
we also got joint warfare look you're
doing jiu jitsu you're lifting you're
running
your joints are going to take a little
bit of abuse joint warfare
krill oil you can just go on to those
just get on them
just get on them and don't look back and
if you have to look back you'll be
looking back at sore joints so don't
and by the way so if you want to get on
them and say on them subscribe
yeah so go to jockofield.com order them
subscribe to them
and then shipping's free you'll get it
for you get the stuff shipped to you for
free you won't have the
mental lapse like some people used to in
the podcast
used to have where they would forget to
order don't let that happen to you
uh disciplined powder we got vitamin d3
and cold water those are
also just just sort of staples of life
yeah right staples of life you're not
getting enough d
vitamin d it's not happening get it the
proper way
yeah it's one of those things too where
you get in the routine you got the
subscription all that is it's just part
of the routine you don't have to worry
about those effects anymore that's the
big one you don't notice it
but it's better to not notice it than to
notice when you don't notice it in a
good way
you're not like damn my knee hurts damn
my elbow hurts
you're just going damn i'm looking
forward to training today yes exactly
that's what you're getting
yeah that's true if you need a little
extra protein
get yourself some mulch i ate two ribeye
steaks last night
for dinner that's good and i'm all i'm
gonna say
and and it was a triple monk so here
this is
this is an is not a normal thing for me
but i went like
you know start to i was on fast and what
do we call it when you you don't mean to
fast incidental fast
what it was yeah then it was like man i
f incidental fasting
it was getting kind of late i was like
man i didn't eat anything today
so i'm just eating one time essentially
and it's gonna be big i'm gonna
gotta go big so yeah two rib eyes brown
rice how big are the rib eyes
the regular size one okay so those are
big yeah they're big they're not those
thick thick
monsters but not the thing regular i
have an image yes sir we're talking
probably 14 to 16 ounces
you know probably about a pound yep
that's like a regular ribeye it is a
very normal person yes
because my rib eyes are those thick ones
yeah the thick ones are good too but bro
you think i'm gonna eat two of those i
don't know
you know i'd have to be pretty hungry
put it that way but then the trip
what's a triple mulch you said it was a
triple mulch three scoops okay
two big fats in fact it was so big the
milk was so big like my stomach was
getting like way too big
but it was tasting good so i pounded it
but i didn't mix it with regular malt
milk half milk half almonds see that's
the thing with the banana
thing and i gotta say you know people
like think i'm
closed-minded about you know nutrition
or i'm closed-minded about
my habits because i am a very habitual
person but these things that have
recently been introduced to me coconut
milk
uh almond milk oat milk like i've been
trying these other milks and what's nice
about them is if
if you get that little lactose
i'm not lactose intolerant like strictly
but if i drink a whole bunch of milk
let's face it we're not feeling great it
might have some effects
yeah so you mix up the milk with the
almond milk or the
coconut milk or whatever kind of other
milk that's out there
you're you don't know you don't really
know the difference
it still just tastes like a freaking
dream yes so the the almond milk
obviously there's a plethora of
different types of almond milk sweet
sweet bark milk or whatever exactly
the particular one i did was the
unsweetened it's super like
milk to me does doesn't taste sweet at
all milk is not sweet
but apparently it is because unsweetened
almond milk is like
whoa like you can taste the unsweetened
goodness of it
so i did a half and half and but with
the milk and the banana
boom you're good oh yeah 100 disappear
it was essentially
a dessert mm-hmm an additional there was
like a thousand grams
you ate so much protein yeah though
why can't you train today uh i have some
prior engagements
okay but why can't you train today well
maybe if it was later
like it may be like five okay why can't
you drink today
it was bumped out of the stuff all right
so we realized we trained hot i mean
i don't know if you thought it was hard
but you know
okay you know when you get into like a
routine working out training you don't
feel doms as much you don't feel
like every once in a while like i'll
have one with greg yeah and yesterday
was
was actually kind of intense one with
you
where the next day like today when i
woke up i was like you had full body
dogs
full body like like i got hit by a truck
like
you've been rolled over you did
essentially you know what it was it was
that choke
that i was trying to defend that you
didn't have sunk in but you had it tight
you know that kind of stuff so you feel
like oh i can defend but i'm gonna take
some heavies on this
and i'm like defending trying to build
that and then at the end it's like all
right it did
you know what's bad about your choke i'm
just gonna say
so your choke sinks in and it's tight
but you know how most people when they
sink in a submission that's not all the
way sunk in and you feel them like
pushing hard you fee after a few seconds
you feel them let up a little bit for
some kind of adjustment you know
or maybe because you know you can't keep
that intensity on the the application
for that long you know so you feel them
loosen up a little bit
and maybe adjust and then go for it
again or whatever right yours just gets
tight like harder and harder
like it's like your joke doesn't even
get tired i'm like oh my god i'm
resisting it resistant and then yeah for
whatever finally i get choked
so i tap and then like i'm paying this
price for it even after i
tap and then i think he choked me like
again too anyway so i'm like all right
cool
and after you train you're all loose and
you know warm and stuff so about next
day
which is today by the way hurting okay
but we got a train
all right well i'm gonna go train all
right so any of this stuff you can get
it you can get it at the vitamin shop
you can get it you can get the drinks at
wawa yes wawa's fully sp in full support
go get your wawa get yourself a hoagie
a shorty from wawa and a discipline
yeah and a discipline go and um and also
jockofield.com like i said subscribe
we know shipping can be a pain but if
you subscribe you don't even have to
worry about it
it's just coming for free so that's that
also we were talking about jujitsu today
and also at origin originusa.com get
yourself a jiu jitsu gui
just go get one you know hixson was
talking about like oh we were had geez
before we had diapers go look at
pictures of like the the gracie family
when they're little they're all we're
just wearing these
that's true it's funny because i joke
about like hey you can't just wear a
ghee around
apparently yeah if it's 19 whatever 1965
and you're in the gracie family you are
wearing mickey you are wearing a ghee
we're wearing it to the beach where
we're in the market we're wearing it
wherever yeah
yeah that that's that's fine like all
those i got kind of fired up for that
like i'm thinking about wearing a ghee
more often
in more regular situations just
representing jiu jitsu
it's crazy the whole comprehensive
psychological approach that they had
because they
every once in a while you'll hear about
like hoyler would tell us about it where
he'd be like yeah if
you know if you lose your first
tournament you get 20 bucks if you win
you only get 10 kind of a thing
it's like huh that's some weird
psychology not weird but that's some
like
intense psychology like they're thinking
it's not like they're just throwing
people in
and do jujitsu because you have to your
name is crazy it's like there's this
whole kind of thing
so every once in a while those details
or whatever this it's real interesting
that's
that's interesting they were so used to
it just like yeah you just wear the ghee
that's just
wearing the ghee yeah i'm kind of pissed
off at myself that my kids just weren't
wearing a ghee to school when they were
seven years old what are you doing jiu
jitsu
back away so if you want any of this jiu
jitsu stuff or if you want to get jeans
if you decide
maybe you're not ready to wear ghee all
the time like i'm deciding right now
if you're not ready for that cool it's
cool get yourself some jeans get
yourself some boots get yourself some
t-shirts
origin usa.com and the usa part isn't
just like oh it's origin usa we're
calling it usa no
it's cause it's made in america which by
the way is not no
is it is no small feat yes we are making
everything in america even the clay
even
the copper rivets on your jeans are made
in america
the copper is from america the cotton is
from america
some people call it cotton yeah yeah of
course you know what i'm talking about
so
originusa.com go check it out go support
america and support jiu jitsu
and yourself what else is the right way
also jocko is a store it's called jocko
store this is where you can get your
t-shirts hoodies hats with
discipline equals freedom good the
attitude hey someone's talking about the
attitude of good
you saw it in there yeah right yeah 100
oh yeah
so yeah in the toughest of situations oh
yeah one of them men
yeah yeah to the nth degree yeah in my
opinion
the um but yeah you can get uh again
apparel
all this stuff got some shorts on there
good stuff on there we also have a a
subscription
scenario called the shirt locker
different designs more artistic
sometimes more clever sometimes i don't
know it's hard to explain they're cool
go in there check it out jackalstore.com
if you like something and
get something you can subscribe to this
podcast
if you haven't yet if you haven't yet i
don't even know if you should maybe you
should just back
away from itunes and and spotify
do you know that there's a name for
people who uh
who watch videos or listen to podcasts
but don't subscribe what's the name
ninja ninja watchers or ninjas
they just stealth yeah like they'll come
they'll come you know
whatever i don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing i mean it's good if
you're not looking to support
we also could call them what we could
call them freeloaders
freeloaders yeah but it's all free so i
don't know that
that might not be as accurate it's not
asking it's not asking much just to
click that subscribe
right it's not like you're like hey you
know give me your first born child
i'm gonna be honest with you though
straight up i don't even know
what subscribing like does for like
uh for the podcast like i know what it
does for the person subscribing
i do it it's on your feed you get the
thing that's all it's benefits for sure
if you're down for if that's a podcast
you want to listen to
but like why do you care if someone
subscribes
i'll tell you exactly why i care you
won't know why i care listen
we make this podcast to help people out
if someone subscribes to the podcast if
you
whoever's listening right now subscribes
to the podcast that makes
the podcast when it gets downloaded when
you download it
when you listen to it it makes the
podcast more popular
the more popular the podcast is the
higher it goes
in the ranking of podcasts the higher it
goes in the ranking of podcasts
the more it gets promoted inside the
various podcast platforms
various podcast platforms someone that
doesn't know
about the podcast goes i wonder what
that's about seems popular a lot of
people listen to it they click on it
they listen to it next thing you know
they're learning about leadership
they're learning about how to overcome
loss
they're learning about what's doing a
breakup they're learning about jiu jitsu
so you're not just helping yourself
you're not i mean look like you said
does it benefit us directly or oh yeah
you
echo doesn't send me a text going uh hey
you know our podcast is ranked number
three
you're not doing that no but
if it broadens the people that get to
hear this information
that's why it's important important yeah
i guess i
never really thought of the whole chain
and that's assuming that
it does in fact get you higher in the
rankings
oh it it definitely does definitely
assume it does yeah because i mean
the rankings are based on download so if
you subscribe to it it gets downloaded
if you and two of your friends do it
that's three that's true but can't you
download it without subscribing though
and you know what else is weird i forgot
to ask hixon this let's face it
the gracies could have just held on to
all their knowledge right
yeah right oh yeah and just be
dominating the
jiu mma world right now not to not open
any schools
just keep it hidden keep it secret it's
true and other people would try and
figure it out but
it's different different right way
different yeah it's
but the right thing to do and their art
has progressed more
because they opened it up and gave it to
the world that's all we're trying to do
too
so you're just asking to subscribe is to
receive essentially
no way no to subscribe is to help it's
to help other people
learn it's to help this mentality so
that way when you go get a job at some
new
office there's people that are like hey
nice to meet you their ego is in check
they're looking to cover and move and
that you're able to function better and
the world gets becomes a better place
so you guys um in the teams what do
what's the expression
pass the word spread the word pass the
word spread the word
right yep pass the word so we're all on
the same page we're all doing it you're
making the whole place a better
place so like i was saying subscribe
don't forget about we have jocko
unraveling podcasts
that i do with my brother daryl cooper
dc who also has a podcast called
margaret made
a grounded podcast which is about jiu
jitsu i guess we just kind of did a
digital podcast in a way a warrior kid
podcast
as well for the kids out there we also
have jocko underground.com
where we have a little alternative
podcast we do some
some expanded topics we go into some
detail we do a lot of q a that people
can ask questions directly
if you're a member of
jockowunderground.com you got to pay to
be a member
well actually technically you don't have
to pay look we request you pay eight
dollars and 18 cents a month
to be a part of that subscription but if
you can't afford it it's cool
we still want you to be in the game we
still want you to have this knowledge
you email
assistants at jockleunderground.com and
the reason we have that is because
look these tech platforms are very large
and very powerful
powerful and they actually have the
power to
insert advertisements into our podcast
they have the ability to edit or remove
or
whatever ban us i'm not gonna mention
the podcast name
but it's one that's kind of in our
network i know here's the thing
i in fact i maybe shouldn't even say
this but i don't know
the thing is it was randomly removed
it's just removed yeah
from only one specific platform too by
the way
and i noticed the title of it i was like
oh that could be a
controversial title yeah so
we don't want to have any of these
platforms to have
final say on what we're doing so we made
the jocko
jocko underground.com and if you want to
help us out with that
alternative platform if we ever have to
leave these platforms we have a place to
land
and we appreciate the support that we
have a youtube channel
where i am the assistant director to
many of the
superior and amazing videos
that's real fun that's been catching on
that you're the assistant director
what's funny about it it's just you know
what's funny about it is
what's really funny about us is that we
joke about it yeah but what's really
funny is you know it ain't funny it's
kind of true because you know
occasionally yeah you got some good
input you do i do the shot so
go to go to youtube and subscribe to
jocko podcast also origin
origin usa has a podcast channel let's
put if you want to know what's going on
up in maine
yeah yeah go check that one that's a
good one to stay
to stay like kind of in the game as far
as like hey this is what like legitimate
almost in a way redefined american
manufacturing
yeah it is a unique one because of like
the culture of all them and peed and
like all them
yeah it's cool to know what's going on
too right like you order those boots you
can see who made it oh yeah
you can see the thing about that you go
to a regular store and buy a pair of
jeans you have no idea
what you know starving person in a sweat
shop in china
yeah you you don't know right you know
that they got paid 13 cents for their
week's worth of work like
slave labor yeah or you can actually go
to origin usa
and see the people that are making your
stuff and see what they're doing and get
in the game
it's freaking legit main ties up there
doing it yeah doing great work up there
also psychological warfare if you're
having moments of weakness like i
used to not anymore all right maybe i do
sometimes but
if you have those you you want to skip
the workout you have a workout planned
and then all of a sudden you're like hey
man maybe today would be best
to rest but you know that deep down that
that's just you being lazy or not in the
mood and being weak or whatever
psychological warfare he got jocko
helping you through those moments
successfully it's a little album with
track so get that wherever you
purchase mp3s it's a good one and if you
want some cool stuff to hang on your
wall to keep you on the path go to
flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer he has that company and
they're
making cool graphical things
images to put on your wall which is cool
books got a bunch of books hey
this book right here breathe a life in
flow by hicks and grace you just heard
from him there's so much more
information that i didn't cover
i wrote the ford what an honor i read a
little bit of the ford there's a
quite a bit more to the forward to
explain some of these things about
jiu-jitsu
what impact it had on me so get the book
breathe
by hicks and gracie and and peter
maguire another awesome guy that helped
help them write that book final spin
let's face it we don't know what's going
to happen with final spin
people are unsure what final spin even
is
is it a book is it a novel is it a poem
is it a story is it a manuscript we
don't know what it is
literature literature
there's no one that's going to try and
pin it down i i think it will create its
own form of literature
you're going to want that first to dish
so pre-order that right now
the the you know that the publishers are
like well you know
my publisher hears this and they talk to
me about it
so so i need to do it more leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
code the evaluation the protocol
displays freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four miking the dragons about faced by
hackworth extreme ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership these
are all the books i've written thus far
check them out i have a leadership
consultant
consulting company where we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com if you want to get some
of that
we have extreme ownership academy it's
an
online leadership training academy i'm
there
two three times a week answering your
questions
so if you want to talk to me you want to
give me a scenario that you're in that
you need help in
go to extremeownership.com join the
academy
we also have some live events the next
one is the muster in
phoenix august 17th and 18th coming up
then it's going to be las vegas october
28th and 29th
check out extremeownership.com no
actually go to echelonfront.com
and go to events for that all these
things have sold out in the past these
are going to sell out too
so check them out and if you want to
help service members active and retired
their families
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
america's mighty warriors dot org
and if you want to get engaged with
hicks and gracie once again
hixson.academy is where you can learn
his invisible jiu jitsu hixsongracy.com
he's got a bunch of information on there
as well and he's on facebook at hixson
gracie and he is on instagram at hicks
and gracie
jj and by the way hixon is spelled with
an r in case you're
wondering that's the portuguese
brazilian portuguese pronunciation
and if you happen to want more of my
prolonged
pontification or you need more of echoes
obtuse or rating it's not obtuse
if you want more of echoes obtuse or
rating
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on instagram
which echo only calls the gram and on
that facebook
charles i am at jacqueline willing and
thanks once again to
hicks and gracie and the gracie family
for giving us
all the gift of jiu jitsu and also
thanks the gracie family i didn't
mention this but they've spent a lot of
time
teaching our military the art of jiu
jitsu
many of the gracies have worked with the
military over the years to improve our
operational capability it is much
appreciated and to those military folks
that have taken those skills and used
them to protect us
overseas we thank you for that and the
gracie family has also
helped much of law enforcement
and we hope that law enforcement further
embraces
jiu-jitsu as a highly beneficial
thing that will help them in every
aspect of what they do
so thanks the gracie family for that and
also thanks to our police law
enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all first responders who put those
skills
to work to protect us here on the home
front
and now everyone else out there please
no matter who you are no matter what you
do no matter what you think no matter
where you're from or where
you are do me
and yourself a favor
and go train jiu jitsu it will make you
healthier smarter stronger more
confident
more aware i mean i could go on but
suffice to say it will make you a better
person
so go out there and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out